[Laughter]
hey everybody tom had to turn on the
ceiling fan yeah get some air going in
he's having hot flashes
transform it into a minotaur
[Laughter]
not btk hopefully
but we'll see how that goes holy crap
uh yeah so hi everybody
yeah today is going to be the modelo
show and yes modelo is not a gun
all right last time we did one of these
we were talking about doing a well
rebecca
and they were like oh is that a gut no
well it is
but
[Laughter]
i was thinking i was thinking that like
when i called the show that i was like
well are people outside because i didn't
know if like colt 45 like the malt
liquor was for sale like outside of the
us i kind of doubted it but you know you
gotta you gotta keep that in mind
samantha brought up uh werther's
original and i was like hmm where
there's original
i really like those yes i'm your grandpa
um zach says also jen is that a wig or
your real hair i can't tell anymore uh
this is actually a wig although this is
it looks like a real hair though well
yeah i was i had to ask myself i had to
ask also is that your hair yeah yeah
well my hair and actually i just uh
re-dyed my hair yesterday like i dyed
every six weeks or something like the
black you don't have to
dye it as often
so i did re-dye it yesterday so it looks
good but it's still
like three different lengths you know
what i mean because i'm still like
growing out the bangs and i think the
bangs are about this long
and then the shaved part underneath is
about this long and then the regular
hair is like this long so it still looks
a little bit [ __ ] up
you know what i mean so i'm still
putting a wig over until it's all one
[ __ ] length so we'll see how zack
says modelo sucks well that's kind of i
don't know if we're hoping for that um
basically like tom went out on a mission
to the liquor store
and he's like i'm going to go out and
just buy something he's like i'm going
to buy did you say i'm going to buy
something disgusting yeah
yeah that's something that sounds
disgusting it sounds really bad and uh
and so he came back with that and i was
like well i'm not sure because that kind
of sounds good and it wasn't cheap
either yeah they were three something a
can yeah they're big cans but
we'll see so now i'm kind of since they
were three dollars
i'm kind of hoping that they're good
because i would hate to like have spent
three something on the cans and then
but it's uh
it's uh
it's imported into the country by i
think [ __ ] um
uh one of the american companies i
forgot which one it was
schlitz no
it's one of the american beer companies
brings it in
and it's uh
it's the same company
that makes corona
it's basically the same next
yeah which corona i don't like kind of
corona really
have i ever had it probably it didn't
make an impression if i did
yeah zack said yeah medela sucks he's
like i drank like eight cans of the [ __ ]
in a contents contest once and didn't
even get tipsy yeah i mean it's very
very low alcohol content but that's kind
of not why we're not we don't want to
get like completely smashed on the show
even though we do sometimes but um we
just kind of wanted something that was
either like ghetto a [ __ ] or something
that sounded like really really gross or
something that was like really really
cheap or something
yeah this is
this is a kind of a mexican beer that
you drink with ice in it on a salted rim
so i got that set up too
i mean i'm not like i said i'm not going
to be a snob about it because i don't
have i'm a pretty basic [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying i'm not a big alcohol
connoisseur
so if it tastes good and it kind of gets
you like kind of inebriated then it's
fine with me i'm not going to get all
it's not even kind of like a mixed drink
sure
um some of them even put clamato in
there and clamato come out i can call it
clamato
because you're trying to correct me all
the time if they could put clamato in
there and [ __ ] put like
tabasco sauce and ice and and everything
almost kind of like a bloody mary you
can do it that way but this is already
kind of pre-flavored and it's these
flavors [ __ ] sound
wild man
so we'll see they could either be like
really really gross or really really
awesome i can't decide they kind of
sounded awesome like it on that was
tipping the scales for awesome but i'm
not actually really sure how it's gonna
turn out yeah um
danny rowling said pumpkin flavored
beers and ciders next show maybe we
should i don't know if we should do that
those here i don't think yeah you can
yeah yeah they're everywhere
there's all kind of like pumpkin ciders
and beers and everything okay yeah every
oh they're all over not around not in
this town it's got to go [ __ ] with
where the city folk live probably
city folk not in these days i'll go i'll
find it
everything's put man everything's
pumpkin spice although like i said i
don't know like you might have to wait
until later in the year maybe like they
have that [ __ ] at publix man like all
kind of like different ales and stuff
they got stuff and like that in there
everything's pumpkin spice even out here
in redneckville
they've got pumpkin spices
here they got pumpkin spice everything
good um and i think i did it at the
[ __ ] publix
that's what i just said like publix
probably got it and like the and publix
well is that liquor store is that's not
a publix liquor store no some public
like the publix where we used to live
that had its own liquor store but we
have a publix down the street and
there's a liquor store next to it but
it's not a publix liquor store it's just
called does it even have a name no
liquors it probably does oh no it's
called cj's or something no it's called
10 66 or 100 it's like a number okay so
i don't so no it doesn't have a name
right it's just no no name it's just
like liquor store you know what it is
generic liquors are
what it is um
let's see yeah i wouldn't mind doing
that but i really really like uh pumpkin
beers and pumpkin ciders like any
honestly anything pumpkin spice i'm down
for pretty much anything like that so
that would probably be good it'd be like
less of a waste of money
um
zach said jenna you should dye your hair
a ginger color again sometime i saw a
picture of you ginger on an old episode
and you look good with that color well
thank you yeah that's like my natural
color well my natural color now is
probably gray because i'm [ __ ] old as
[ __ ] but um but yeah i have i was i'm a
redhead but to be honest i like that
blue wig so much that for a while i was
thinking maybe i should dye my actual
hair blue
but then i was difficult but it's just
so just so i didn't have to wear a wig
all the time but
i don't know i kind of feel like it's
much easier to just dye my hair black
and if i want like different colors then
i can just like put different colors
like wig on because i had my hair dyed
bright red and it looked awesome
like for a while but
it's so high maintenance yeah continue
to dye you have to dye it like every
time like and every time i had to like
put red dye like in the conditioner and
like comb through the conditioner
because otherwise it'll fade like
immediately
and plus it stains everything yeah all
the pillows would be fun all the pillows
the inside of the shower and everything
like everything was red you know what i
mean
um let me see i saw something else dude
there may be a better die you can get a
hold of it there is like you can go if
you go to like sally like if you have
like a um if you know what you're doing
you could probably get it real right
okay now i didn't even know that this
was a thing but i was watching jade the
libra and she has a beautician's license
she like does people's hair now normally
she keeps her hair she likes her hair
like uh silver like silver white so she
keeps it like that but last year
she dyed it bright orange and it looked
awesome like it looked really really
good but like i said she's a hairdresser
and a beautician so she knows how to do
that and she said
that the
particular kind of dye that she uses
it only
uh sticks to
bleached stuff so even if you get it on
your skin and stuff like that like it
doesn't and i was like holy [ __ ] that's
even a thing now
but yeah it only like react like you
have to bleach your hair first obviously
but i don't know what color her hair is
naturally
but
yeah the orange looks like really cool i
don't know if she's gonna do it again
this year she was talking the other day
about doing another color but the orange
looks really nice i liked it
jenny the mighty booze hunter
[Laughter]
i'm gonna go find some pumpkins by [ __ ]
that's probably like we should do
pumpkin spice all i'm excited because
it's not
i mean i know it's not officially fall
until like you know the equinox or
whatever but
i'm just kind of like i'm just excited
that it's not august anymore even though
it's still kind of hot although
last night
it was kind of cool out it was like 73
right yeah it got it's getting cool
which
is crazy no it gets cool every day a
couple times
yeah well not usually this early in the
year like sometimes at night it does or
like very early in the morning
but maybe because it had been raining
and [ __ ] like that but yeah like last
night like or like yeah last evening it
was kind of it was like 73 degrees and
i'm like holy [ __ ] that's crazy that's
crazy
michael shafer says damn tommy keep up
with them roids and you will end up not
being able to scratch your nose
no or wipe your butt no
no i'm nowhere near big i'm actually not
big
i only i i'm maybe way 190. i don't
weigh that much it's just shape man it's
shape okay
it's not size really
it's shape
rebecca says my my hair is natural red i
put a rinse in it to tone it down now
and then i mean i liked my red hair but
i don't know i just think the black is
more versatile and it's just much easier
to have different colored wigs instead
of trying to maintain i did really like
having my hair bright red but
man after a while it just got to be such
a pain in the ass like keeping it up
and i had to bleach it obviously like to
get it and it made it a little bit
crunchy you know what i mean yeah zach
says [ __ ] indiana weather it was so
goddamn beautiful last fall and i hope
you have an actual fall this year autumn
is my favorite season yeah mine too uh i
wish i lived in new england yeah it's
that's one of the things that i've never
really liked about florida i just wish
that we don't have any seasons there's
no seasons there's seasons here it's
just that there isn't a winner
no i mean what i mean is like there's
really no clear delineation between
the seasons and like don't tell me i've
lived here my entire life i was born
here there's really not really
i mean it's not substantial it's nicer
in winter but
it could still be like it's not crazy no
it's not crazy like for christmas day to
be like 80 degrees that's not crazy
that's happened lots of times like over
my lifetime and i'm not a fan of it
southern california has no weather not a
fan it's like air conditioned all year
round
so we talk about no seasons the place
that has no seasons is california well
yeah that's what i mean i don't really
like any i kind of like a variety you
know what i mean now i don't like hot
weather i don't
so make that drink
oh you're gonna oh you're starting early
he's starting early
half naked you said ha ha my boss thinks
i'm working yeah hey that's all right
that's all right um dark authentic red
hair ginger would look good i did have
it i was kind of experimenting with
different colors like for a time like
because i bleached it out
and then
i think it was
i did it purple for a little while like
kind of not lavender but kind of like a
medium purple that looked nice i liked
that but i didn't keep that too long
and then i did
then i did like a dark red
like a cranberry type color was it
cranberry
i guess or more like a brick red i can't
really remember but then like i did the
bright red and that looked amazing but
it only looked amazing
if you
pretty much dyed it
every week like i had to put dye in it
every single week and i couldn't wash it
all that much like and then when i did
wash it i'd have to like put dye like i
said in the
bottle with the conditioner and then
like comb it through and leave it in
there so that it wouldn't fade because
if it fades and goes pink it looks like
[ __ ] it looks like super super shitty
but
when i just did it and it was why it
looked like it looked incredible but you
know
okay oh [ __ ] i forgot my little forgot
my little uh
oh you even holy [ __ ] even though like
salt around the rim and everything
[Laughter]
oracle said when you dye yarn you learn
that red is a color best described as
easy come easy go yeah and it's sad
because i think probably
red is my favorite color but
it's and it's weird because you see it i
don't know why it's red particularly but
in florida like if you have a like for
example like a bumper sticker or you
have a red car
um that will absolutely fade
many times faster than any other red
here just pink that's yeah
essentially all right this is what i got
modelo it's a shelada okay
and it's uh
spicy orange spicy spicy orange spicy
orange i guess that that doesn't sound
bad
we'll see
we'll see
tom's gonna try it first and tell me
what he thinks about it
okay
it looks pretty
all right did you pour it like an
[ __ ] no i poured it all right
[Laughter]
i'm always like i always make a
reference to beer and board games
because matt always he just pours it and
like lets the big head and he's just
like look i poured it like an [ __ ]
because it's like all head and no beer
and they keep like giving them [ __ ]
about it
i'm i'm not really sure what that face
implies
try it
i don't know if that's like that's
really good or that's really terrible i
liked it oh it smells good i liked it
you know that's not bad
it's pretty good
that's not bad at all pretty good take
another belt of that
the salt on the rim helps
it's kind of a
it's a beer
it has i like it a sweet orange
flavor
and it tastes slightly like uh
chili
yeah a little bit like chili
hmm
or taste the chili aftertaste yeah
try it again
yeah i see what you're saying
it's nice
it is actually that's actually i would
buy that again yeah
i would actually buy that again that is
that is actually like quite right
that sweet and salty is mixing or if
that rim
caused my mouth to water
yeah
it's good
let's see what it tastes like just
straight out of the can
i mean everything is always better over
ice
gonna say what's it like out of the can
okay it's okay better like that like i
said it smells good yeah
yeah it's still good yeah i mean it's
much better much better with a spicy
than with the salt yeah but it's good
out of the can i would drink it like
yeah i would absolutely buy that again
there's nothing wrong with that at all i
was surprised
it's not cheap though
so yeah i mean three
it was more than three dollars it was
three something three something per
capita per can it's a big can i mean
it's a big can i'm not saying that but
and that's the flavor that has the
that's the most boring sounding flavor
that i have the other ones sound even
wilder so we'll see
but uh no back in mexico mexico did not
disappoint my friend
camp guy said sam adams has big uh
oktoberfest beers we buy the assorted
case yeah i think i got that a couple
years back
but uh yeah it's a lot better than colt
45. yeah and then and that wasn't bad
that wasn't bad that wasn't bad actually
but that's that's actually nice i like
that i like that
it's a mess up okay
no turn it
there's no salt on there there you go
why can't you're drinking all the salt
yeah
you'll see what i'm talking about i'll
make your mouth water
yeah i know yeah
hugo said uh regular modelo is a good
beer and dark modelo is better than
guinness
that's quite a bold statement
i don't think i've ever had like a
regular modelo this is kind of a
light and refreshing
summer
brew uh they're trying to come at you
kind of like a dessert beer
wouldn't you say yeah but it's kind of
has um the spicy undertones
to it
that chili tastes slightly like um
oh caspian what what i'm thinking of uh
no not casting what do you call it [ __ ]
what are the capstay caps no it's that
it's it's a it's a red chili it's real
hot
oh i know what you're talking about yeah
cayenne
oh okay it's kind of like cayenne chili
cayenne pepper you're talking about
capsicum
well i think capsicum comes from cayenne
that's yeah it does but um i thought
that's the word that you were trying to
connect it has that it has that flavor
to it that tastes like
a little bit like cayenne pepper at the
end it is giving me like a little bit of
the heartburn see that you
it's hot because it's hot it's sweet and
hot i mean it's not super hot no but it
has it it has a like it's as hot as
black pepper is but it's the it's the uh
it's the flavor of uh
cayenne
danny rowling asked granthars
uh while you were a cop did you ever
hear of any paranormal stories happening
to other cops
grampher said the only time was a lady
came in and wanted to report that aliens
were on her roof
i asked as in mexicans yeah no she said
as an aliens from outer space yeah well
you're gonna have to like give me some
more information about that like so did
you go out there and did you actually
see any aliens or
zach says uh jenny have you seen copycat
yes i have i actually think i saw it in
the theater now that i'm but i haven't i
don't think i've seen it since then uh
sigourney weaver said it's the
performance she's most proud of i
remember it being really good because
holly hunter was in that too right and i
always i really like her honestly i've
been wanting to like re-watch that movie
because i think it came up on
one of our streaming services i think i
even put it in the patreon poll like a
couple times but it never won i don't
know we'll get around to it probably but
i think like the next matinees we have
to do we really need to do godfather two
for [ __ ] sake yeah we gotta give him
and um we should do sicario too because
louie sent it to us so we'll do those
too and then like for monday
for a haunting i think we should do the
calling because you keep bringing that
one up
you know what i mean i'm pretty sure
that that's the one with the guy that's
like this is my house i'm pretty sure
that's okay yeah yeah where somebody
said it was that one okay
because i wrote it down like last time
so i was like yeah the black ghost maybe
we should do most of them things the
[ __ ] ghosts are white this is a black
ghost
i wasn't expecting that [ __ ] white
house
oh yeah of course white people to come
back and ghosts but you never hear about
black people come about well they're
just like
it was sally's house i think she comes
was a
it was a female black female ghost oh
was it i haven't i don't remember that
episode it's been a long time
well the only 13 of the populations i
guess is just less likely on this
continent
over in africa well maybe they just
can't be bothered you know it's like
they die and they're just like why the
[ __ ] i want to hang around here
i'm going in the next button i don't
want to hang around haunting you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i got better [ __ ] to do dude in this
[ __ ] cowboy house this is my house
yeah okay you got it bro i'm out of here
camp guy said i just hit the jackpot on
some cuban sandwiches ooh that sounds
those are good use big fluffy french
loaf and toasted bread and lard to add
flavor with a little butter press into a
panini pressed pan dark golden brown oh
my god that sounds simple yeah it makes
me sandwich it's good
for those you guys that don't [ __ ]
know uh florida food man we got some
cute one of them is cuban sandwiches
cuban sandwiches are really good mojito
oh yeah
which actually i think mojitos are
puerto rican i think they're puerto
rican but they're here this is
they're they're super famous in in
in uh in florida
south florida is basically kind of like
an extension of
damn the bahamas in a way or something
it's kind of like the
it's like central america but it's also
just a bunch of islands it's kind of
what it feels like
pirate place man when i lived in tampa
you could get a good cuban sandwich
pretty much everywhere yeah man they're
the best [ __ ] cuban sandwiches i like
a good cumin sandwich every now and then
uh let's see
help me with some of this that's the
last of it help me help me
that's a that's a lot in the community
it doesn't really seem like okay well
i'm not mad about it being three
something dollars done because that was
easily like two full glasses yeah
that's a lot of alcohol that's like two
two um regular beer cans
what does it say on the back ooh thank
you half naked you what do you say lame
i gotta go back to work my boss is rude
making me do my job damn you hate it
when you buy i know i can read it jen i
[ __ ] hate that too um i love y'all oh
we love you too i told him man said i
could he looked at me like i'm a lunatic
man
[Laughter]
you tell him that man said you could do
whatever the [ __ ] he wanted
[Laughter]
all right man
if you've got any if you've got a
problem with that you [ __ ] pee in his
closet all right just gonna say that
exactly it's like let it fly
let it sit in it let it let it sit in
there and marinate for a [ __ ] week
yeah oh my god
so gross so yeah thank you so much
didn't you want to read what that said
on the back
oh yeah yeah
well i wanted to see what the uh what's
the serving size oh they don't do that
oh we're not doing that okay i guess
it's mexican
okay they don't have to do that i was
curious as to what the serving size was
they're like a can that's a serving size
obviously or we wouldn't have made it
that size but i'm like that looks like
at least two that's two servings
according to wikipedia modelo is a big
ass cannon
i think i think modelo was imported into
the united states through anheuser-busch
in mexico it's the same company that
makes corona but i don't know
if corona and modelo are mexican brands
like
just like in a lot of central south
america countries even the united states
and australia they have export brands
brands that only export
so i don't know if that's something that
exports only
but uh tacon of ocelon if you can find
modelo the the flavored uh what's called
micheladas
and they had micheladas in brazil yeah
uh we they kind of did that too um the
orange one is [ __ ] good man the
orange chip this the uh what's called
spicy orange yeah it's good
good uh better than corona a lot more uh
character than corona
what's this say on i can't look it's too
dark in here there says government
warning yadda yadda good with ice on a
salted rim
uh 3.5 alcohol by volume so it's weak as
[ __ ] it's weak yeah yeah that's weak and
[ __ ] brood and canned by modelo mexico
imported by crown imports chicago
illinois made with natural flavors that
could mean pretty much anything because
pretty much everything's natural really
yeah i mean you know
to greater lesser degrees
yeah it doesn't really have isn't that
interesting that it doesn't have maybe
alcohol doesn't have to have that like
you know how food has to have that yeah
the label on it but it does have an
orange flavor it is it is very orangey
yeah
yeah
um i like it i think it's good yeah
it's just a light refreshing beer yeah
flavored beer
nothing wrong with it it's good
that's what you'd have on a hot day yeah
gram there says uh sicario has one of
the most real police gun fights in
movies so yeah we're gonna yeah we're
gonna do that we'll either do it
because like i said we gotta we gotta do
godfather two at some point because
somebody like they sent it to us a long
time ago and we still haven't got to but
we did the first godfather but um and we
gotta do this one so
we'll do those either like sunday or
tuesday
zach said oh [ __ ] can we talk about how
surreal it is that the queen died
honestly it's like i yeah i saw that
really she was still alive after all
this time that's what i was just gonna
say i'm like man she was old as [ __ ] but
i guess that's what happens when you
live your entire life in luxury and have
the best of everything like you can
[ __ ] live forever you know what i
mean like well not forever they had a
lot of money a long time yeah that's
what i'm saying so she was cute when she
was young real cute she was yeah real
cute but what she she got uh
she got queened when she was what 26
yeah something like that she was young
like when she got turned into yeah like
back in the 70s you know when she's
doing the little [ __ ] queen
coronation things and the little things
that they do the little things they do
yeah
whatever the [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] it
is that they do i don't really know
probably not fun to hang out with though
i don't imagine i don't really imagine
that anybody that lived a life that
sequestered or that
uh that isolated from normal people
would be all that fun to hang out with
you know yeah
because you really have to think they
live their lives in such a bubble not
only because they're money but also
because they're like really famous
so you travel in certain circles that's
what i'm saying so it's like you can't
really like hang out with them just like
as a normal person because they wouldn't
you wouldn't have anything to like
relate to them about
what was it one of her sons see this guy
who was her son or a husband or whatever
said that he wanted to come back as a
virus and wipe out the [ __ ] human
race
that was looking weird i saw him say
that
he said it like half jokingly but you
just like you know i didn't think he was
joking yeah now
was that was that uh is it prince philip
i think it's was it was her husband
prince philip yeah
i think
okay if that's who i'm thinking of then
yeah he was always kind of like a joke
in the uk because he would say like this
is [ __ ] crazy just [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
and they were just like whatever
okay
like i know there's some uh british
people here so please tell me
i just i remember i think it was like i
remember eddie izzard making a bunch of
jokes about it's like it's prince philip
he's a card what's everybody saying in
here
uh they're talking about the crown that
show which they said yeah that's like
the best drama i've ever seen on tv i
think they spent 15 million bucks per
episode
um
john smith said uh there was a funny
scene yesterday people trying to sing
god save the queen outside buckingham
palace
but had to stop because no one in the uk
knows the words
that's excellent i love that
um they said that the queen was real
into tv she liked doctor who
so you know
what's up dave uh hello just got out of
work stopping at taco bell on the way
home and then getting ready for a great
friday night at mannequins okay yeah
we haven't been to mannequins in a while
we should probably get one of these days
we just haven't had much money yeah
money and time there's a bunch of other
stuff happening and
i was thinking he was talking about
going out and i was thinking i want some
tacos and then i was like the thing is i
gotta make some more refried beans i
gotta go down there and [ __ ] put
those in the easter pot
i like having refried beans on hand
because for some reason i wanted to be
bean taco
that's just weird how like the drunkard
you get you'll probably be like although
last night
he made
a
meatloaf yeah
made two beetles you mean well two
little meatloafs yeah because yeah that
was the thing like you'd made a baked
chicken prior to that like wednesday
night i think like but then
last night
i don't know it was probably like six
seven eight o'clock and i was prepped up
to go though
and i was watching
uh
masterchef yeah because you know i
watched because they do the two episodes
on whatever [ __ ] channel it's on fox i
watch it on hulu like the next day
and they put up two and so i was
watching that and he's like i'm gonna go
down and make some meatloaf and i'm
listening
i got another one god speed got another
one sitting down there do you really
yeah we had some for lunch had something
i gotta eat up we gotta eat up the taco
meat
well that's fine too yeah i gotta let me
know that left and then meatloaf for
taco that's fine they seed up the taco
the taco meat yeah he's like and now
he's all gotta get rid of now he's all
like fixated on tacos yeah what's one
piece of media i mean don't start we're
only like half an hour in so you're not
gonna be able to eat tacos for like a
couple hours like calm down
john smith said prince philip is famous
for saying [ __ ] up [ __ ] in public yeah
see i thought he was yeah he's on the
road such as asking an ambassador from
an african nation if he still ate people
yeah he says like really really dumb
like out of touch stuff and it's almost
kind of like
i kind of feel like it's like a running
joke over there
i like the [ __ ] stupid shitty thing
i'm gonna put the same thing crazy but
you know there's a lot of inbreeding in
those second royal family well
i mean that's not i don't think that's a
controversial thing to say at all
because like you're not the only person
that has said that yeah
you know i mean you know
and like i said it's not it could be a
combination of inbreeding and as i said
not uh interacting with normal people on
a day-to-day basis
so
they can be they seem like they're
completely out of touch and always
happen
so you know
well
most like uh what they call elites i
don't like calling them elites they're
not nothing to lead about them they're
just ultra rich people the one percent
and then the [ __ ] upper one percent
of the one percent they don't have
anything in common with regular people
they're [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know they just
they look at us like we're [ __ ] scum
john smith said but fun fact prince
philip was worshipped as a living god by
the cargo cults i remember reading
something
we should do a show about cargo cults
have we ever done that no how could we
have not done a show about i always
found that really great on an island
somewhere and they were waiting for them
the british to come and make [ __ ]
fake runways and fake airplanes and do
everything they could to bring the
airplanes down
i thought that was so awesome i just
thought that was really awesome that
whole thing
hugo says happy birthday to jeffrey
combs it's jeffrey combs birthday today
how old is he today i don't know
happy birthday jeffrey
we love you we love you on the show
please come on the show
we never asked him i'm scared too we'd
have to uh we'd have to uh get a hole
you need to like show you like befriend
him and okay we could have him if he
comes if he ever be seen maybe he could
come over
i don't know where he lives
he probably does live around here he
might live right
he could come over and we could drink
and like you know you could make some
you could make some dinner it'd be super
fun
talk about the resonator right
yeah
and we'll get him super [ __ ] up it'd
be like
combs loves to drink on uh
when he's when he's on shows as a guest
he can control it but i ca you know i'm
an experienced drunk i can see it in
another man he because he goes i'll be
back in a second okay you go i'll be
back i said he goes [ __ ] good takes
down yeah we were watching that and i
was like oh my god he's over there like
getting [ __ ] up and i was like and i
love it oh it was so funny though and he
still has he's still uh [ __ ] uh he
can hold it okay he comes across as
jeffrey combs not drunk jeffrey carl
just comes across as jeffrey combs you
know i know he's [ __ ] up
he just seems like he'd be like a
[ __ ] hoot to hang out probably fun
yeah he just sounds like because he's
like he's kind of weird but like in an
awesome way yeah you know he just seems
like he'd be a [ __ ] hoot
he's amazed that people know everything
about his career
and they have collected things that he
that he worked with see that is so cute
to me and like i said i that is one of
the things that is one of my favorite
things about horror fandom
is that
these actors that [ __ ] maybe nowadays
like aren't even doing anything for
anything and you know they're old now
but they can go to like a horror
convention and every single [ __ ] there
will know who they are and i'll be like
can i take a picture with you and they
want their autograph and like
and i think that's so cool and like some
of them like really because we've been
to a couple horror conventions i've been
to several horror conventions and some
of the people there are just like so
like the actors are so appreciative
because they're like i can't believe
like you guys are still like there's
20 year old kids there that have seen
all their movies and like know who they
are and they're like old as [ __ ] now and
they just think that's so awesome comb
was getting loaded on that show
and he said he said some [ __ ] you know
they were talking about his work on star
trek enterprise
which i love enterprise
it the first season was kind of spotty
but it started really picking up and
then they they [ __ ] up
they kind of dropped the whole temporal
time war [ __ ] thing but um
combs jeffrey comes one of the best
characters on that and he would show up
as guy i think it was named commander
tran or general tran i don't know i
think it was commander tran
and charan was an indorian
[ __ ] captain he's kind of like kirk
he's more like kirk than than [ __ ]
archer was
just this [ __ ] macho
[ __ ] andorian [ __ ]
worship captain
and he came up with a good idea he was
just like well what they're doing with
star trek now there's licensing problems
and it's just not the same and he goes
what would be great is if we just
did a whole series as
with commander shrand
as and his in the kumari as
and and that would have been [ __ ]
great yeah like do a spin-off series
everybody everybody would watch that
yeah i would watch that instead of
having it about a federation ship it's
about an indorian [ __ ] warship back
then
okay
back before kirk and there with no
humans on it
no humans in the in the series that have
been great
that have been really good that's
actually a great idea yeah
and you could relive kind of like that
kirk that brashness of [ __ ] kirk
but it would be it would be he wouldn't
even be a human he would be a he would
be an andorian
and that would just
that would give plausible deniability to
the to the riders they said well this
isn't uh this ship is not a united
federation ship this is of these are
basically the bad guys so we can have
adventures with these guys that you
can't have
in any kind of federation type ship
and they were a century or so ahead of
everybody else so they had more
technology they were kind of like the
where kirk was in the old series
so i thought that would have been great
he had a good idea that is a good idea
and combs could carry an entire series
oh i absolutely am yeah sure and that
character sran could do it
and he was he was like kurt
he was a good guy
good guy serving a bad government really
yeah see and the thing about it is there
are so many goddamn streaming services
nowadays that you think that somebody
would pick that up yeah [ __ ] man there's
like a million shows that i didn't even
[ __ ]
realize existed
yeah that are on like a bunch of
streaming services you know what i'm
saying yeah just today for example
i found out while i was recording my
video that i'm gonna put up tomorrow
about my top five favorite movies that
came out in 1975
i discovered that picnic at hanging rock
was
sort of remade as a six episode
miniseries in 2018 which is on amazon
prime
and i'm like i mean originally it wasn't
made for amazon prime but they had it
that uh i think the australians made it
and then like it was on bbc and stuff
like that i was like i didn't even
[ __ ] know that existed and we have
amazon prime i don't know why i didn't
like [ __ ] see that so i gotta watch
that now but you know what i mean
oracle said tom have you seen any of
strange new worlds uh no i uh
i kind of refuse to see anything cbs
i you have to pay for it it's behind
firewalls
and i heard that out of the cbs star
trek stuff
strange new worlds is the best one
but
i've also heard it's not worth it that's
not that good i mean the thing about it
though is that if you really wanted to
see it you could just pay for a month or
two until you watch it all and then
cancel it right i mean
i think a lot of people do that yeah
they're just um
cbs has a bunch of conflicts with uh
licensing so everything has to look
different to a certain percentage
and they changed everything up and the
people that are writing don't know star
trek they're not star trek fans
they're just pulling things out of their
ass
and um
hoping that that's star trek
kind of like what some of that star wars
that disney's is making those aren't
star wars
fans making that those aren't people
that even know about star wars with the
exception of the mandalorian the
mandalorian was [ __ ] great those
first two seasons that i saw they were
really good
but uh people are saying that the other
stuff that's come out of there is just
garbage so
i just i'm not gonna give him any money
you know
everybody the obi-wan kenobi was just
garbage
i'm not bothered i mean i just
honestly i don't i usually like to see
things for myself or i don't really have
an opinion on it you know what i mean
well i've seen them explain why they're
saying that and it is written kind of
like bad fan fiction whoever's writing
this stuff
didn't see the original movies
okay probably never played into the
video games
that's the great thing about the
mandalorian what's that guy that made
him fervo is that his name or john
fabric bro
that's the same guy you've seen he's in
the spider-man movies yeah he's good
yeah
he actually
either played the video games some of
the old video goes to the 90s or at
least [ __ ] has a good writing crew
because their [ __ ] from video games and
old toys appears in those he's super
into it he's a nerd totally into that
[ __ ] yeah and he'll interconnect a bunch
of [ __ ]
you got to you got to
you got to love [ __ ] star wars and
star trek to know how to write it okay
the the people that are
writing both of those series mostly
outside what i just mentioned they don't
love that [ __ ] it's just a job for them
and uh they just hand them out here you
write this
and they whip it up real quick they
don't have any background in it they
don't know who kirk is or spock or they
don't know any of that so
i'm just going to come out and say they
don't have a right
to [ __ ]
write any star wars star trek shows
even the people that did next generation
they saw the original series
most of those people that wrote they saw
the original series those were iconic
and they did things that kind of fitted
fit along in that world yeah they went
out on their own they did some really
cool [ __ ] in next generation
but evidently picard is so bad that if
you watch picard
it will make you not want to see next
generation again so i don't even want to
[ __ ] see picard
they say that that's [ __ ] just
terrible
and it's the writing i would think
though that i mean if it was me and i
understand this is just me but if i got
hired for example to write for a show
and it was based on some beloved
intellectual property that i didn't know
jack [ __ ] about well one i don't think
that i would apply for that job in the
first place but two if i
was given that job the first thing i
would do was go and do like a whole
bunch of research about like i would
watch all the old [ __ ] and i would like
try and read as much as i could about it
so i'd like get the vibe of the [ __ ] you
know what i mean yeah
in recent
in recent times
the best star trek that's out there that
is not canon okay or the best new star
trek is star trek continues and that's a
free
on youtube
because they're not allowed to charge
for it
there's fanfare made and they give you
the last season of the old star trek
series series with
spock and kirk and it is [ __ ] it has
a lot of the same people that worked on
the old ones
and it's [ __ ] perfect that's star
trek
they got that [ __ ] right
if they wanted to make star trek again
or [ __ ] they should have hired they
should have taken star trek continues
and gone back
to the kirk spock era and make
everything look 1960s
60s version of sp
that would have been [ __ ] hip and
[ __ ] everybody loved it because you know
you had at that time you had
you had [ __ ] fallout and fallout had
that retro futuristic 1960s space age
you could have done this just so cool
the cbs are they're retards you know
they're [ __ ] stupid
uh
they sunk so much money into that series
and blew it
star trek [ __ ] what's it called
star trek discovery
even the ship didn't even look that good
it's just
i kind of feel like if you're going to
do that at least probably like retro is
the way to go because it'll make it more
distinctive if you just try to make it
like just a generic sci-fi thing it's
going to be just a generic sci-fi that's
what it is now they say it's generic
that's what i mean and like but because
in the ensuing decades we've had so much
sci-fi
that looks a particular way that it's
like if you want to like make yourself
stand out you have to go back and like
make it kind of retro yeah and that
would totally work everybody look like
people love retro [ __ ] yeah look how big
[ __ ] strange your things was for
questions yeah yeah i'd have made it
retro futuristic dude right the new star
trek kind of looks like it's a high-tech
version of the damn 60s with jetson's
style [ __ ] in it and [ __ ] but it
looks credible you know it's not a
higher budget and [ __ ] people would
have loved it and you could have had
kirk and spock
and all the old [ __ ]
the old crew members and you could have
gone into a bunch of different [ __ ]
directions with that
and it would have been like
season four season five season six of
the old [ __ ] show
okay but you're bringing it in a new way
and then you can make that up with the
[ __ ] movies
you know what i mean
you're making it up with [ __ ]
or actually maybe it was maybe you could
make the show
in between
wrath of khan and [ __ ] undiscovered
cartrige or whatever the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that was or [ __ ] voyage home or
something like that
there's a bunch of stuff that could have
happened between
motion pitcher and wrathicon that must
that look like that must have been about
six years right there
you know
you could have a whole series right
there
yeah there's a lot i mean the universe
that star trek established is so fast
that there's like lots of little slots
that you can kind of like make some [ __ ]
out you could have middle-aged kirk and
[ __ ] spock older spock and different
people playing them because they got
actors that can do it oh what's his name
does a [ __ ] great spock the guy who
did [ __ ] star trek continues
um
what's his name [ __ ] [ __ ] todd
haberkorn what no no haberkorn played
spock and i liked him as spock
uh the guy who played kirk oh you said
spock yeah yeah we're right there kirko
which is vic mignon
yeah he's [ __ ] great kirk
he'll have you believing you're seeing
cap
he'll have you believing you're seeing
shatner but he's not doing a shot
impersonation
he's doing it
like that but he's he he did a thing
where he did a shatner impersonation
and he could see it would suck if i did
the role that way so i just did it you
know
you know the way i thought captain kirk
was not so much the way shatner was and
he which is yeah that's absolutely the
way to right right
it's funny because i've been watching
like i said i've been watching uh the
unexplained on hulu which has william
shatner as the host yeah and
he just cracks me up on there like
because when he does like the
introduction whatever the show is about
i think the last one i watched was about
like outrageous robberies or something
like they talked about the collar bomb
murder and all that
um you know robbery and he's just always
kind of like
but what if the thing and the thing
happened like that
that's what we're gonna find out it's
like i don't know it's like every time
he does that it just like cracks me up
uh rebecca said bloody streaming
services i can only afford netflix
very few streaming services are
available in australia we need to buy
like an 80 uh australian you know
australian dollars vpn to then access
and pay for a streaming service that
sucks man we have let's see
tom pays for netflix
and
i have i think he also pays for amazon
prime but i also have an amazon prime
like uh
subscription also so i can watch my own
[ __ ] in here and he watches stuff in
there
um i also pay for hulu
i pay for shutter
but i pay for it yearly so it's a lot
cheaper like that i think it was like
57 for a whole year so it's like really
really cheap
and i have i also have hbo max but that
came with my phone plan
so
you know yeah i pay for it but it came
as a perk with my phone plan
so
do we have any other ones other than
that what's that
i'm trying to think of the streaming
services we have netflix amazon prime
hulu shutter because those are the ones
we pay for got the british box oh and
brit box we also have bread box which is
like an add-on
medela
medela
enchilada
pina which is which is a pineapple
and it's called picante
pina picante so hot hot pineapple
or spicy
the other one said spicy hot pineapple
own rebecca said back up i do have
disney plus also
yeah for a while we had somebody gave us
their password for disney plus so we
could watch the mandalorian but it
doesn't work anymore but it doesn't work
anymore yeah
so but we have a lot and there's free
ones too like there's tubie and pluto
and voodoo
and
plex
like i'm trying to think of all the apps
that we have so those are all free like
you can watch a bunch of [ __ ] like for
free on there with ads so
between all those we can usually find
what we're looking for and if we out if
we absolutely have to really really want
to watch something
usually amazon prime will have it to
rent for like 2.99 or 3.99 or something
like that only every now and then you do
come across a movie that
you can't rent anywhere which is crazy
in this day and age might assume do the
licensing well yeah it obviously it does
but i mean it doesn't really happen all
that much anymore but i have come across
a couple of movies now and then that i
wanted to watch that aren't available
anywhere
zach says uh jenny have you ever thought
of doing graphic design tutorial videos
that has occurred to me but
i don't know i'm kind of one of those
people that's like well i kind of feel
like most of the stuff i could tell
people they could probably figure out on
their own i don't know
i don't i don't know if i have any likes
any kind of like vast knowledge or
anything like that
what's that one do you like it or no
you try it
so this is hot pineapple hot pineapple
hot pineapple
with a salted ring
okay it smells kind of like the other
one just tastes like a nice belt just
take a nice belt of it
i love it
all right that's pretty good i think i
like that better than the other one i
don't know it's pretty damn good that's
pretty damn good too mexico [ __ ]
delivering
yeah that's actually pretty nice it's
not hot though
i think the spicy orange well the spicy
orange one was hotter yes
um that one doesn't seem hot to me
because like i said if stuff is hot
it'll like give me a medium content is
spicy yeah okay
this is says picosa
picosa
piccos
picosa
spicy and spicy
yeah spicy and more spicy more spicy
it's not that spicy the spicy orange was
more spicy that's what i'm saying but
spicy oh okay i thought that was the
other can okay
yeah that's good
i'm favorably impressed that's good
that is quite good again i would buy
that one again too that's that's yeah
i'd be a because that's quite nice
that's good
it's good it has a
nice caribbean
central american
flavor to it
if you're in um
europe if you can get it
try it out
try it out
definitely designed for hot weather
danny rowling said does it taste like
pineapple yeah it does a bit yeah yes it
tastes more like pineapple than anything
else yeah
it smells like pineapple too
it's not quite as orangey as the orange
like you know
it's not as pineappley as the orangey
one is orange does that make sense yeah
but
it's still like noticeably pineapple
it's like you took
a light pilsner or something
and threw a shot of um pineapple juice
from the bottom of a damn pineapple uh
can you know a can of
pineapple chunks or something you put
that in there pineapple juice and maybe
put a little
a little bit of cayenne pepper in it
or chili powder
good to give it a little bit of heat at
the end
it's good pineapple might be my favorite
fruit
i don't know i like watermelon a lot too
so it's light and sweet
with the salt on the rim that helps to
give it a little bit more of a
the sweet and the salt kind of hit hit a
resonant frequency when you're eating it
which makes it kind of like savory
and then it kind of has a slight amount
of heat in the back end
there's nothing wrong with that yeah
that's actually pretty good there's
nothing wrong i think i like that better
than the spicy orange
yeah it's not it's better i would um
like i said these are
something you drink during hot weather
which you know it is yeah it's florida
so kind of like imagine if a um
it's not malt it's not one of those malt
liquor drinks like a white claw or
anything
it is it's definitely beer
but you see that they're trying to
compete with that kind of stuff yeah
that's what they're doing
they're like well we want a flavored
beer
that has kind of a lighter
more playful
quality to it
i don't think there's anything wrong
with that man yeah that's that's
actually quite yeah
uh michael shafer said does pineapple go
with grits everything goes with you
everything goes great
[Laughter]
everything but most things you can make
grits grits is a blank canvas
okay
i've seen grits
you add in the grits butter a little bit
of salt
brown sugar
um
what do you call it
brown sugar and then what you basically
what you're talking about is like
pumpkin pie spice yeah all spice okay oh
i already [ __ ] out of that all right or
cinnamon okay which that's in all spice
too all right and then peaches
out of right out of the can
what you can do is you can take the
peaches and you can cook them in their
syrup
separately and once they start to
caramelize a little bit pour that into
the grits and then you end up with grits
that's kind of like peach cobbler
really good
yeah there seems to be like kind of a
thing where
uh you know it's kind of like the whole
like thin crust like uh thick crust
pizza debate where people that like
grits are either savory grits people or
sweet grits people yeah because you can
do them either way yeah
i like them both ways normally i'm a
savory grits person right but they're
good sweet too i'm not gonna like hate
on that so but i know a lot of people
that like would eat them with sugar and
stuff grandpa said at galaxycon they
have cosplay speed dating trekkies never
romantically dig star wars people and
vice versa debate and discuss
but um i've actually uh that's hilarious
assad from saudi arabia who's a fan of
the show
he sent me a damn
a link showing a quick
recipe
some um dude
some uh black dude in uh
in louisiana
doing shrimp and grits with the cheese
and he and he was like yeah that does
look good
now that one had bacon in it and he said
he's muslim he's i need bacon but i said
you can use turkey bacon or you can omit
the bacon
yeah i mean i've had really good shrimp
and grits without bacon in it it doesn't
have bacon in it yeah but uh shrimp and
grits is another fine fine way of doing
grits
makes me want something i got a [ __ ] ton
of it i know we haven't oh i even got i
even got [ __ ] velveeta cheese
and cream and we haven't even been to
chantal's in a long time
they make amazing shrimp yeah well she
uses uh she uses damn coconut milk and
hers instead of grits that's why the
cream that's why they're so good well
that's i mean and like we've said like
they don't um we usually if we end up
with chantels it's like the middle of
the night yeah because it's right next
to mannequins but
they don't do shrimp ingredients in the
middle of the night you have to go in
the daytime yeah to get that but
in the middle of the night they only
have they have chicken and waffles i
think that's their main thing but yeah
they mostly just have kind of like fried
like catfish and stuff like that
um i saw something you'd probably like
what's that small pancakes yeah
with two
eggs okay
and you can kind of like soft boil them
or hard boil them or something in little
cups
then you put
uh
um over the top you put that on top of
the
pancakes right
and then you pour hollandaise sauce on
it and guacamole it's supposed to be
pretty damn good
yeah
guacamole okay
and it's supposed to be kind of like uh
a different take on um eggs benedict
yeah
which is also delicious so instead of
sweet pancakes it's [ __ ] it's savory
pancakes
well yeah again a pancake is a pretty
yeah
that's a pretty blank canvas it's really
kind of just like a quick bread right
yeah you wouldn't need you wouldn't need
the the the up the uh
the uh
waka sauce uh what it called guacamole
you wouldn't need that
you could just do
poached eggs and hollandaise
on pancakes instead of
english muffins see sure
that'd be good too cheese would probably
be good if you put them in between swiss
cheese slices of swiss cheese in between
the pancakes
sound good yeah okay well see that's the
nice thing about all the american style
breakfast foods
all of them yeah
go together it doesn't matter like if
it's sweet or savory or whatever you
could do any combo of that [ __ ] and it's
delicious swiss cheese and slices of ham
it's like yeah i'm gonna have pancakes
and then i'm gonna have like some
sausage and then i'm gonna pour maple
syrup on it and then i'm gonna have like
eggs and that also has maple syrup on it
and it's all good
with hash browns it all goes together i
saw a video from
all goes together some irish people
freaking out over [ __ ] pancakes they
liked them
i love pancakes i used to make them ice
and make them all the time pancakes
bacon the syrup and the damn
butter
although when i although when i make
pancakes like i'm not saying i'm not
hating on like the fluffy like the big
fluffy ones
but
i tend to like pancakes that are more
like crepes yeah i like really really
thin
with the pancakes that are a little bit
crispy on the water yeah you make them
thinner that's well yeah that's what i
used to do like i used to make them just
water it down
because they would say like you get the
pancake mix and they're like i don't
even remember what the ratio was but i
would use skim milk usually and then i
would use like way more than they told
me to so i would make them like really
those irish when those irish people were
eating those pancakes and everything it
was pancakes eggs bacon and syrup
and they'd never have because these are
[ __ ] great and when the irish girl
says i don't like that syrup
she says that ruins everything it's like
cough syrup and she goes this would be
so much better with beans and they
[ __ ] went get the [ __ ] out of here
they [ __ ] hell up
that was one of the weirdest look look
i'm not hating because well yeah that
was one of the weird things when i was
in the uk like well because they turned
on her they said you'd never put beans
on this yeah but the thing about it
though
is that the
you know the whole the full english yeah
breakfast which is kind of similar to
the one we have over here
but they always have like beans with
their like bacon
it's kind of like yeah like canned beans
um
and i've seen too like when i first
moved over there like back in the 90s
sometimes they would have like
like canned spaghetti on toast
for breakfast which i was just kind of
like terrible are you trying to give me
heartburn this is early in the day jesus
christ this for you british people this
is
this is what you're supposed to do with
canned spaghetti whether it be can't
speak throw it in the garbage
take that [ __ ] you open the top of it
and throw that [ __ ] right
through not supposed to be [ __ ]
having canned [ __ ] spaghetti now i
will definitely raviolis are okay i will
hey i will defend chef boyardee yeah but
not spaghetti no spaghetti meatballs is
pretty good it's mushy
okay it's overcooked it is it's mushy
it's overcooked but i don't mind it i
don't mind it uh the ravioli is better
and there's no spices in it it's just
but
i mean it's it's okay like if you don't
have anything else to eat i don't mind
chef priority but
but
uh i would never eat that for breakfast
though because like my my stomach could
be like the [ __ ] are you doing all right
lady let me educate you brits out there
you guys
will go and grab a can of those [ __ ]
beans those nasty ass beans
survival beans they're heinz yeah like
heinz yeah we have them here yeah we
have beer too we have them here but we
we don't need them for breakfast though
and we don't eat them as they are
that's a component okay
um
what you do with that
i mean unless you live in a trailer
right
i gotta pee all right what you do with
that
is you get two or three cans of that
and you open them and you put them in a
big mixing bowl
and then you squirt a bunch of mustard
in there
just a regular french's mustard prepared
mustard squirt some of it in there
like maybe
i don't know
if you got four cans in there
maybe like a quarter of a cup maybe a
little bit less than about about a
quarter of a cup just
be generous
and then you want to put dill relish on
there which is dill pickles diced up
if you have to make it or you can get
delrose you put some of this you put
some dill relish in there
and then you take probably about if you
had four cans of those beans take about
a half a cup of brown sugar and put that
in there
and then you mix it
okay and if you have any onions
saute some onions put that in it and
then you put it into a big glass into a
glass
square
pan
and bake it or a round pot with a lid
put that in like a
little earthen round pot put that in the
oven and bake it and reduce it
until it gets low
until it gets kind of candied and sticky
okay
you won't taste any mustard in it you
won't really taste the
the the dill relish it'll all kind of
mellow out it'll just be kind of
thick
kind of sweet
and salty
and slightly candied all right with that
that's good with anything now what you
do is to serve it
with a serving spoon take take up take a
portion out use it as a side put that
next to whatever it is you're eating
boom and kind of like mashed potatoes
make a little hole in the middle and
scoop some sour cream and put that in
there all right
you'll thank me
you will thank me
when it comes time to eat just kind of
mix it mix some sour cream in it mix the
sour cream around it and eat it it's
beautiful
but you don't eat those out of the can
you turn them into baked beans
and i think some people call those
boston baked beans i think
with the sugar yeah yeah yeah sugar in
the mustard particular thing
john smith said fun fact baked beans are
served with damn near every meal no
matter what in english prisons yeah i
kind of feel like they do serve baked
beans with everything which i think was
a little off-putting i've never i'm
gonna say i've never really been a fan
of baked beans baked beans in the u.s
i kind of feel like that's mostly like a
summer picnic food right like you kind
of have and we bake them you have steaks
burgers hot dogs
corn on the cob coleslaw
or what a potato salad and baked beans
that's kind of like the quintessential
hot dogs of july
huh eat it with hot dogs that's what i'm
saying hot dogs hamburgers that's what i
said pork chops if you're eating fat
in the south whenever we had those baked
beans like i just told you to make
we were eating those mostly with mostly
with pork chops or chicken fried steak
and some what the [ __ ] is a chicken
fried steak get a piece of low quality
meat and you [ __ ] bang it out with a
[ __ ] mallet chili and you flip it
over
meat tenderizing mallet
and then you throw it through egg wash
and roll it in um
in uh
fry mix which is just flour salt and
pepper with maybe whatever seasoning
you want
the same seasonings you use for chicken
do it on both sides if you want it thick
you can double dip it batter it again
and fry it in a pan of [ __ ] bacon
grease or drippings or oil
so you're taking a piece of pounded out
[ __ ] meat
it's usually something low quality
and you're frying it the same way you'd
fry a piece of chicken
and you take that and you put that on a
plate and you put country gravy on it
which i got a recipe for that in our
recipe book it's a white
gravy with black pepper and little
pieces of
sausage yeah it's like a peppery white
sauce the peppery white sauce is gonna
put that on top of it and you'll have
sides
like collard greens and grits
or rice
or different kinds of rice you know rice
pilaf next to it
now if you don't have
a piece of
meat that you can pound out turn into
chicken fried steak
you can also take a hamburger patty and
do that and it's also really good yeah
my grandma did that sometimes just take
a hamburger patty make it out a little
bit thin
batter it roll it in the fry and fry it
and it'll come out it'll have a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
crisp crust on it
just like you fried chicken
you take that and you can just put the
same country gravy on it you can put
brown gravy on it but i have to put
country gravy or you can put it inside a
toasted bun and make a sandwich out of
it
yes indeed
or you can take that
chicken fried steak patty
and throw it into a [ __ ]
metal bowl
half and half melted butter and [ __ ]
louisiana hot sauce and toss it in there
that's what buffalo chicken is
so now it's buffalo chicken flavored and
you put that in a bun with lettuce
and [ __ ] blue cheese dressing on it
thin sliced onion
and some pickle
you will thank me later
he will thank me later you'll never find
that in a restaurant that's hardcore
southern deep south a [ __ ] chicken
fried
a chicken fried hamburger patty as
buffalo chicken
really good
i haven't seen that outside mississippi
thing about it though is that you say
you'd never see it in a restaurant but
you know like in the past
five to ten years
there's been a big thing of like
restaurants doing like
home food hell of elevated like southern
dishes elevated southern food well
people are starting to recognize that's
what i'm saying so like all all that
kind of stuff you know can be found in
restaurants nowadays the secret of all
culinary art
is to take a common low-cost piece of
food and a component and turn that into
something
something elevated and artistic that's
delicious okay well see just like like i
said i've been watching the last the
latest season of masterchef which is
still going
and one of the guys that's in the finale
christian is from
new orleans
and he made
on the semi-final he made an elevated
fried green tomatoes oh yeah and they
said that [ __ ] was delicious how do you
do it i can't remember but
i can't remember what about all he did
to it
what'd you do with it it looked good
though
we grow we can have gardens i got a
garden out here
we'll grow tomatoes
i'm drinking yours problem is you might
be hungry before the tomatoes are ready
you might have some green ones out there
before the harvest is done
you can eat that if you cook it
so you get you some big green tomatoes
you bring them in you slice them
you roll them and uh you do
some people will batter them some people
don't but you i put them in egg wash and
then roll them through seasoned corn
meal
and deep fry them
and they almost come out like a damn
little hamburger patty and you can do a
lot with that you can use it as a side
you can make it a sandwich
depends on what you put on it oh he put
caviar on his caviar i would have done
that among other things but but they
said they thought it was sounded weird
but like when they tasted it they're
like oh that absolutely worked because
it salted it yeah salted it yeah i can't
he put some other stuff on there too but
i can't remember but i do remember that
he put caviar in there i just watched it
last night but i can't remember because
i was like keeping track of like the
other recipes to you but another one
that grows real well my i might get
around to doing this in the south okra
grows real well
the only problem with okra is that it
doesn't have much nutrition
you know that's the only thing
but i'll see
think i should grow some okra you want
some okra i'm not a huge fan of okra um
i don't i don't mind it as a component
yeah like in gumbo or something like
that but
i don't really like it on its own yeah
okay you know what i'm saying see the
thing is is if i'm going to do gumbo
it's mostly because just got to be damn
i'll just give gumbo excuse me if i'm
going to do okra it's going to be fried
okra
see fried okra is good i mean fried
anything pretty much is good
so
but other than that i'm not really i'm
not really a fan of it for for what i
have out there i can either grow more
tomatoes or more or more eggplant and
see eggplant yields like [ __ ] crazy
yeah but we have so much [ __ ]
eggplant dude we haven't had eggplant
about a month now but when it comes it
comes it's inside i thought you made it
i didn't you put it in that curry which
that you just made the other day no
there was no eggplant in that oh okay i
thought there was eggplant in there nope
i thought you just made that thai curry
the other day that had it planted it
oh that was a month ago over a month ago
was it yep the next time we'll have
eggplant is two months
okay
yeah that's weird i thought you just
made something when it comes it all
comes at once
rebecca says barbecue beans at kfc in
the usa we don't get any beans as a side
in australia i always thought it was an
odd side dish for kfc
because it tastes like baked beans only
with barbecue sauce like i said i'm not
shouldn't be barbecue sauce they're
they're fooling you it should be the
ones i described pretty much they're
slightly sweet like i said i'm not i've
never been a big fan of baked beans like
i'll eat them but it was never really
like if i'm doing picnic food yeah like
for example if you go to publix you know
and you get their deal where you can get
fried chicken you get a bag of fried
chicken and then you get two sides yeah
and rolls for however much it is 8.99 or
12-minute or whatever the [ __ ] it is
so uh i never get baked beans yeah i
usually get potato salad
and
mac and cheese yeah those are usually
like together they have coleslaw they
have like other kinds they have a couple
different kind of potato salad the
american big beans that they have at kfc
here don't have any don't have any um
barbecue in them i don't think i've ever
had the baked beans at kfc because like
i said i'm not into baking so i would
never get it i usually get you know
baked they're pretty much mashed
potatoes they're pretty much like the
ones i described except they have a
little bit of green pepper in them
and they they might be have a little bit
of sweet in them but just not as much as
what i like
the best side you're ever going to find
really in the american
fast food restaurants
is popeyes [ __ ] red beans and rice
and yeah popeye's red beans and rice is
actually the best reds red beans and
rice you can get
it's much akin to
mcdonald's french fries
it's hard to beat mcdonald's french
fries
i've never really had a
i've had a lot of good french fries
hard to mess up for hardest to be honest
but mcdonald's french fries are really i
think the best ones
yeah like the standard although like i
said i was a big fan and i don't even
think they do this anymore this was like
a long time ago
kfc used to have potato wedges like the
big wedges that stole the skin on them
ooh i was really into those because man
if you're gonna make french fries i like
the big planks man like and i like the
skin still on it and all this because
i'm i like baked potatoes too but
yeah i mean if you're gonna have like
thin fries mcdonald's are kind of like
the gold standard
but
yeah i mean i definitely think that
popeye's red beans and rice is
you know again like the gold standard
that's even better than like some people
make in their houses
and like a lot of people say that to you
uh hugo said popeye's mashed potato is
good you know what i don't think i've
ever had have i ever had popeyes mashed
potatoes
we don't go to popeyes that much because
for a long time there wasn't one
near us
and then they built one
near our old house and i think we went
there maybe once or twice and i don't
think i even got a side i think when i
went there i just got a sandwich and
that was it so
i don't even think that i don't even
think that i've ever had their mashed
potatoes i love mashed potatoes though
we had mashed potatoes earlier today
actually with the meatloaf
they had like
cheese and green onion green cheese and
green onions i don't remember what he
put in them but they were good
kevin says tomatoes are nightshade never
eat green ones if you have a nightshade
allergy yeah that's probably a good uh
pro tip
and let's see yeah i don't get
i don't know like i said i'm not a big
fan of baked beans so that i think
that's why i was weirded out like i'll
eat them now more than i used to when i
was a kid because when i was a kid i was
like blood i don't want that
but then like when i moved to the uk and
people were like eating them with
breakfast i used to think that was
really really weird like because
you would go and get a full english
which i'm on board with um you know i
like the whole eggs and it's tomatoes
and mushrooms and stuff yeah that's fine
but i'm like i don't want [ __ ] beans
with it that's [ __ ] gross what are
you even talking about
but
camp guy said we call all beans baked
beans also pork and beans i usually
don't use the word barbecue because they
come automatically at all picnics and
cookouts
yeah i kind of feel like that i don't
know how it is in other countries but
baked beans here that kind of thing is
always that's like picnic food yeah when
you say barbecue here there's a certain
mesquite flavored tomato sauce that we
use that is
like craft barbecue sauce it's
like ketchup
but smokier
and a little sharper in flavor uh
ketchup is kind of sweet
sweet and neutral tomatoey
but not barbecue sauce when so when you
say something's barbecued
well usually when you say black
barbecued beans it's got that damn
barbecue sauce in it that's what we're
saying that's what we would say yeah
it's got to have that particular flavor
like even barbecue potato chips it even
has to have that kind of flavor to it
yeah the most common seasoning would be
hickory
which is a smoke smoke comes off a
special kind of wood really good
sesame said the fries are the only good
thing at mcdonald's i just agree there's
a lot of stuff that's good there's
actually like a actually they're sausage
and egg mcmuffin
i
actually really like i don't like the
mcgregor i like magrib but i like the
sausage and egg clay and fish thank you
jeffy art thank you thank you so much
says thanks for being you with a little
pear the the double filet of fish
the [ __ ] i kind of like the flavor
actually they're chicken sandwiches with
the veggies and stuff on there the
crispy chicken and stuff is actually
like pretty decent yeah and i can i can
eat unlimited uh big macs
you know i've seen him do it yeah i can
eat four of those
and it's really
there's just something about a big mac
is not a great hamburger
a big mac is just a big mac it's a
special flavor that you're it's mostly
has to do with that lettuce and that
thousand island dressing that's on it
yeah
and the the texture
there's just something about it it's
just
when you grow up with it
when you go to mcdonald's it's you want
mcdonald's there's something about yeah
i mean a big mac when you're thinking
when you really think about it it
doesn't even like really taste that much
like a good like a really good hamburger
you'd make at home
no
but
it's a very distinct right product
flavor profile yeah that sometimes you
just want that well like i said i kind
of feel like that's why a lot of people
[ __ ] on you know for example taco bell
but yeah
nobody is arguing that that's actually
authentic tacos because it's not or
authentic mexican food because it's not
but sometimes sometimes
that's just the flavor that you want
like you know it's shitty or you know
it's not
really like a taco
you know not really strictest definition
but that's still kind of what you want
if you took that [ __ ] to mexico they'd
[ __ ] laugh at you the best thing
about the mexican best thing about the
[ __ ] taco bell taco is all that
lettuce i love all that lettuce on it
and the cheese cold cheese
and i could eat like 15 of those things
i can eat like 15 of those damn tacos
they used to sell them in big [ __ ]
packets
you can get like 10 of them for
[ __ ] five dollars remember that
remember those days i don't think that's
around anymore i was never a big taco
bell person i could sit there and eat
all the things man they came in a big
[ __ ] on the rare occasions that i
wanted like drive-through tacos i would
usually go to dell taco yeah but
those aren't everywhere those are
hardcore i know they are there's only
like two of them in the whole orlando
area so sometimes like if we really want
to talk or if somebody i was with really
wanted tacos we would get a del taco i
did like the del taco
you could get like a couple of the small
chicken tacos and you could get french
fries on the side which i thought was
like what i think of the mcrib i like to
make rib see i don't like it circle k
has a mcrib all right but the thing is
it doesn't have any taco it doesn't have
any hot uh sauce on it
so what i do is i buy them on the way
back from the [ __ ] club but i'm drunk
i said yeah let me get one of those and
you i disassemble it go down there and
disassemble it
i'll take the the meat off of it and put
barbecue sauce because i got a lot of it
here i take them
take the meat off and take the hat it
comes with pickles i take the pickles
off i just put the patty on a [ __ ]
piece of on a plate that's what takes
you so long
i'll put a barbecue sauce on it and hold
the pickles on the side and then i'll
take the bread and put that in the
toaster
okay and it all comes up around the same
time and then i'll reassemble it
and it's better than an amer than a
mcdonald's mcrib it's very similar
better got to doctor it up dock that
[ __ ] up kind of how to cook it
but uh
man
circle k's got good sandwiches
they go see i'm usually if we're coming
over the club i'm usually sleepy
and i'm just kind of like using
everything i know but it's like i don't
really want to like have to heat
anything up in the microwave because i
don't want to wait so i was like i
usually just buy a cold sandwich i
usually just buy like egg salad or
chicken salad if you take the if you
take the uh uh the
the the breakfast muffins with the with
the
sausage and the egg and the cheese leave
it wrapped
just put it in the microwave for 30
seconds it comes out great
but some of them you you have to
disassemble them and toast the bread and
then
microwave the meat and get the sauce
although i will say that it's hard it's
harder to mess up a breakfast sandwich i
mean usually especially if it's on like
a really nice like croissant or
something like uh you're not expecting
it to be crispy
so right just you could just steam it
and as long as it's yeah and it's good
like that too it's good like that too i
mean because i back in the old days like
every now and then i'd get one from
7-eleven yeah and you just heat it up
like you said for about 30 seconds and
that [ __ ] was delicious yeah like on a
croissant it doesn't have to be crispy
or anything like that it was just kind
of like steamed and it was warm and nice
like i said
breakfast foods
it's hard to mess them up yeah very very
hard to mess them up
um kevin says uh shamrock shakes in
chicago
yeah shamrock shake hell yeah
explain okay let me explain a shamrock
shake although imagine shamrock shake is
available everywhere in the world where
there's a mcdonald's i would think yeah
i would think so uh what season is that
that comes out in do you remember well
st patrick's day st patrick's day so
it's march march
it's a green shake
that is mint flavored
creamy mint
i don't think it has chocolate does it
not that i know of yeah
but it's just kind of like mint ice
cream
and it's just a shake like that even
though i'm not sure it's a shake
so many people told me that there's no
ice cream in that no but it's pieces of
gelatin
well the mcdonald's shakes are not i
mean they're not like steak and shake
where they actually make their shakes
with you know ice cream and milk like a
shake is supposed to be they're powdered
it's like a powdered yes
which you know so the thing that gives
it the ice cream texture is probably
some kind of gelatin little microscopic
yeah it's like an emulsifier type
situation sure but it's uh they're all
right though it's just a light green
mint
shake that's [ __ ] good really good
but the thing is is it's
it's just that you're just going to get
that at mcdonald's
so you kind of get addicted to that
specific taste
you couldn't replicate it at home not
really
i mean you probably can and i'm sure
there's a million youtube videos that
are telling you to do it because the
thing about the [ __ ] to do well like i
said nowadays any anything at any fast
food restaurant you would care to name
all you have to do is type in like
shamrock shake dupe and somebody has
made that [ __ ] yeah so all these things
they've made dupes of all the
starbucks drinks they've made like all
you can probably get that powder
well yeah if they can get it you can get
it yeah
it's not like the old days right now
there's some stuff that i was like how
the hell they did how the hell did they
do that
if you go to um chick-fil-a
the chick-fil-a sandwiches are not quite
what they used to be it's because
they're baking them now
they used to be pressure cooked in oil
and you can still do that
you take a chicken breast and you soak
it overnight in pickle juice that's how
they do it
get the pickle juice and then you get
the breast out you want a big jar you
want to do a bunch of them at once
you get the damn
breast out
batter it put it in the
in in fry mix
and then you drop it
in a pressure cooker that has a little
bit of oil in the bottom of it about
that much
and there's i forgot the cooking
instructions but you're pressure cooking
it in the oil
there may have been water in there too
no i don't think so it was just oil
and when it comes out it comes out like
old school
chick-fil-a
where you can tell that it's fried
but it's pressure cooked and it's
it's done in like a few minutes
it's good real good
remember when i did that one yeah it
came out perfect
although the key was soaking it in that
pickle juice so yeah it does it because
it gives it that chicken yeah dill
pickle juice
that's what the secret is yeah
rebecca said i'm guilty loving
mcdonald's in australia mccafe was an
australian invention yeah that's right i
love their coffee hey no [ __ ]
mcdonald's coffee is there's starbucks
yeah i mean depending on what you get
yeah but just in the regular because i
usually get iced coffee like with
hazelnut or something like that and
that's just better
than
well a lot of people say that starbucks
regular coffee i'm not talking about
like the blended drinks and stuff but
like a lot of people say the starbucks
regular coffee kind of tastes burned but
i think that the reason that they do
that is one because they want like a
specific flavor and two because most
people order
stuff that has like a bunch of
flavorings and ice and whipped cream and
all these other accoutrements in it so
so they're yeah so they're just kind of
like well we have to make the coffee
like stronger or more burned so it like
kind of all evens out like the flavor
maybe that's what i've heard anyway
uh rebecca said no shamrock shakes ever
down here
they don't have them they're in
australia now oh they're good
i mean i guess not because why would
they have st patrick's day
[Laughter]
it's a st patrick's day thing it's just
a light green shake
just like the strawberry one or the
chocolate one or the vanilla one it's
it's light green it's mint
it's real good
and they only have it in march yeah like
right around
st patrick's sake
michael schaefer said remember the
mcdonald's banana shake from the 1970s i
don't remember that one ooh i vaguely
remember that but i was probably like i
was probably horrified because i don't
like bananas i love it
i don't like i don't remember i don't
like banana flavored anything i would
have been like [ __ ]
offended but very existence of it
i'm old enough
from california when i was a little kid
we had this [ __ ] [ __ ] called derwener
schnitzel
yeah everybody that's [ __ ] that's like
that's pretty iconic i feel like
everybody knows i hated it my mom liked
it [ __ ] she go let's go to the winter
stencils there was some [ __ ] she would
get there was other [ __ ] i was like i
don't like that i understand there was
something i could eat there that i would
get
i didn't like the way winter schnitzel
smelled
but i just did not like things that were
kind of like hot dogs when i was a kid
just how about you you wanted to have
burger
i think part of the deal was that she
was getting damn sauerkraut i couldn't
sauerkraut on the
on the hot dogs i couldn't stand
sauerkraut well now you love sauerkraut
now i love it but when i was kid i
couldn't stand it i still i still don't
really like it it couldn't stand the way
it smelled
yeah it doesn't smell good
i'm still not a fan like i'll eat it but
because we because you've made it a few
times you made
like you made like pork in the pressure
cooker and you put sauerkraut and stuff
like i'll eat it but it's not really my
favorite thing i'm not a big fan of it
not a big fan of it just a way of
getting rid of cabbage pickled cabbage
it's good it's good with mustard
on pork chops and certain kinds yeah
it's it's okay like i said it's not
myself it's not my favorite thing it's
not my favorite thing
rebecca said uh st patrick's day is as
big here as it is in the u.s we do have
green beer okay so they don't have the
champagne you
need need to [ __ ] y'all need to write
it yeah i mean it's not that good like
it's probably gonna calm down
[Laughter]
i only have they only have the mcrib
every now and then that's a seasonal one
and i think i mean my my uh
theory
is that people only like get all like
exalted about the
mcrib because of that because of the
limited availability because i don't
think it's that good otherwise oh i did
i've had well i i'm not a big fan of
like barbecue style sandwiches anyway
like i'll eat them but it's not really
my favorite thing again so it's just
kind of like so i don't really get
i'm just like yeah and it's like it's
not really that big of a deal to me
so
i don't know like when people get all
[ __ ] rapturous about it i'm just kind
of like oh my god settle down
rebecca said yeah mcrib is available
maybe once a year
yeah it only appears sometimes yeah
but they've they've been smart to like
keep that going because it ups the
demand like when they're like hey mcrib
is coming out everybody everybody loses
their [ __ ] mind and like goes there
to eat it but like i said i'm not
[ __ ] on mcdonald's because they
actually do have some decent sandwich
like their fries are good their coffee
is good the salads are good yeah some of
their salads are good and like i said
some of their sandwiches are good
honestly i'm i'm a big advocate of the
quarter pounder i think the quarter
pounder is probably their best burger i
think it's better than the big mac it's
nowhere near as bad as people want to
make it out to be no it's improved a lot
yeah it's approved a lot when i was a
kid there was some shitty stuff that
happened at mcdonald's but
in the modern era
you have to understand
mcdonald's is not a restaurant this is
something that i heard some french
people talking about oh i said american
food's terrible it's all like they're
the [ __ ] they're talking about
mcdonald's is not a restaurant
americans do not consider mcdonald's to
be a restaurant
amer [ __ ] mcdonald's is a fast food
joint
it's basically a glorified [ __ ]
vending machine you drive through it you
get food instantly that's all it is
it's not high cuisine and it doesn't
represent american food it's corporate
it's a food factory
it's pretty good though
you know they've got it down to a
science
the idea is that it's the same
everywhere all the [ __ ] time
no matter where you are in america
you're at home because those [ __ ] are
there it's just like home you can eat it
yeah it's the same and it tastes the
same tastes exactly the same
i mean i kind of feel like mcdonald's to
me that is where you stop when you're
drunk after the club yeah or if you're
going on a road trip and have to leave
somewhere really really early lunch
break at work um and you drive through
to get like breakfast and a coffee
that's kind of like what that's how i
think of it that's not really somewhere
that you would go like for
a meal meal unless you were on youtube
with the family and relax and [ __ ]
right no that's not what that is
rebecca said mcdonald's is honestly way
better than 20 years ago worldwide um
food standards though in each country
changes the taste yeah i mean i the
thing that's cool about mcdonald's
though is that whatever country they're
in they'll like offer stuff that's
you know more um
kind of in line with whatever
the local cuisine is which i think is
kind of cool like even in the u.s like i
think in maine and [ __ ] like that like
mcdonald's up there have like lobster
sandwiches and stuff which i kind of
wish we had down here because i would
eat the [ __ ] out of that but
i'm sad that like more
fast food places don't have more seafood
options
because i really like seafood and i wish
that that was easier to get like we
mcdonald's has filet a fish which is
okay but it's it's kind of its own thing
burger king has a fish sandwich which is
also okay
and
we have long john silvers but they're
getting harder and harder to find
nowadays and to be honest a lot of that
stuff is like way too salty
and that's about it i kind of feel like
the only other
i mean down in the south we have captain
d's but that i mean i guess that has a
drive-through does it but that's like
more of like a sit-down restaurant
and that's good but
i don't know man like they don't really
have a lot of like fast food
there is no fast food
seafood place
because i guess it doesn't i guess
enough people don't like seafood so it
wouldn't make it like [ __ ] but i
don't know you'd think like in this day
and age when they have [ __ ] fast food
everything else
damn it's just i don't know it just
makes me mad
that they don't have
fish sandwiches like in a lot of places
and louis says late to the show how was
the modelo can't go wrong with that beer
in my opinion of the yeah we've had um
we got three cans like three big cans
and we've so far drank two of the
flavors
one of them was spicy orange
and one of them was like hot pineapple
and both of them were quite delicious we
also had the i mean tom had the whole
glass with the salt on the rim and
everything i thought they were really
good they're both really good i slightly
preferred the pineapple one but they're
both like absolutely decent and i would
absolutely buy both of them again
uh hugo said carl's jr has a one-third
pounder burger is really good i don't
think we have any carl's jr around here
is that i think that's just a west coast
thing
we don't have we have hardee's which i
think is owned by the same company but
hardy's is uh not great
okay here's the granddaddy of them all
oh this is is this the weirdest one or
what mango chili oh i'm probably not
going to like this one because i'm not a
big fan of mango chili flavored things
oh i forgot to get the ice
you guys said i like wendy's fries
and wendy's is that the one that does
the square burgers yeah they're square
well um
i was gonna say i thought steak and
shake did square burgers too but i guess
they don't are they around i don't know
i've been a long time
they're kind of like smash burgers zach
says i'm trying to imagine red lobster
with a drive-through
you know what i'm not gonna hate on red
lobster but the thing about it is that i
mean they have like some decent food in
there if you want seafood that's pretty
much like i said
if you want like a casual
seafood experience bread lobster is
pretty much the only game in town other
than the captain d's but red lobster is
like maybe one notch above captain hook
you get several notches actually but red
lobster the only thing about that is
that even though they have like a bunch
of delicious food every single [ __ ]
time that i eat there it's just too much
fried [ __ ] like at the same time and it
just fill up and it just like legitimate
like as soon as i eat there i'm just
like yep gotta throw up
you throw up no but it's like i always
feel like i'm gonna throw up
like after i after i eat there
okay
mango said somebody say my name
because mango yeah
jeffy earth said i love red lobster's
cheesy biscuits yeah they're good they
are good what do you mean
you can buy them in the store i don't
know
i've never bought the ones that are
available in the store so if anybody's
bought the ones in the grocery store and
made them are they just as good as the
ones that are in the restaurant i'd
imagine probably not
yeah that's what i said you can buy that
red lobster biscuit mix in grocery
stores
but yeah those are good but that's the
thing it's like maybe that's why they
like they give you all those cheesy
biscuits and then like i try to only eat
one and then they bring you your regular
ass food and then i'm just like oh my
god i don't think i can eat all this
i tried in a while we had to go actually
yeah that's true we haven't
when was the last time we went well
because yeah because every time i go i'm
just kind of like i just want to eat it
all and then like i eat some and i'm
just like oh i don't feel good man this
is good is it yeah the mango one yeah
mango says so is modelo a beer yeah it's
a beer it's a mexican beer it's b yeah
these are like flavored beer
this is what tom got at the liquor store
today i didn't know what he was gonna
get i just said go get something weird
or gross or crucial or ghetto or
something
which is i didn't give him any
parameters it's a light flavored beer
that you oh that's really mango it's
really good
just take a belt of it with the ice or
with the with the uh
salt
mango chili
oh yeah yeah yeah look at her face look
at her face that's good you can drink
that one that's good that's really good
well i don't really i don't like mango
flavored things
that's really good it's okay but i like
the other ones better i like that one
but i knew that was gonna happen because
like i said i'm not a big mango fan
the only the only mango thing that i
like
is
the mango ice cream
at the indian restaurant that you go to
memories of india they make their own
mango ice cream and that [ __ ] is [ __ ]
delicious okay they were all good uh out
of the three that i had i'd recommend
this one
oh yeah i think this one is the is the
is the most intense experience it's good
it is yeah well that one okay i will
admit that that one tastes most like the
fruit that is that is very very mangoey
it smells very mango and it tastes very
magical and it's got a very um they were
all good i think my favorite one was the
pineapple that was good too they were
all good
it just had a good and has a good chili
aftertaste
kind of like a smoked chili
yeah it's good mango said not sure about
having ice and beer though but then i am
english i mean normally people don't
have ice and beer here either it's this
type of beer it's just but just because
these are kind of more flavored yeah
kind of beer
situations
yep then it's acceptable it's a
considered to be a drink a mixed drink
that's based in beer right yeah normally
you would not normally you wouldn't do
that you wouldn't drink even in the u.s
you wouldn't drink water with ice in it
people
that'd be like putting ice and wine
people would think you were a weirdo
although the ancients did it i know but
i'm just saying like nowadays if you did
that people would look at you like okay
it's uh
like a mixed drink uh it has a beer
flavor but it's like a it's like a very
it's like a light pills in her
kind of
and
with a tropical flavor and with a spicy
back end on it of chili
like
a smoked chili flavor it's good it
tastes very central american good real
good well and you guys said uh yeah
technically like uh the michelada is
served with ice that's what i thought
yeah it's a dessert
kind of mixed drink let me try it again
like i said it's very mango-y it's very
sad it smells just like a mango very
central american
profile
and it's kind of like a tropical drink
like a tropical mixed drink
with a with a spicy batter it's not bad
i don't mind it it's good but like i
said i'm not a big fan of mango things
mango flavored things so i i think i
like the pineapple or the orange ones
good too they're all they're all good
i think the pineapple was my favorite
you don't have a beer experience
yeah it's not real berry no it's more
fruity yeah it's more like a
it's more like a
fruity mixed drink
with uh savory aspects and spicy aspects
to it there's just no way to describe
it's very
central american very mexican
very mexican
which um yeah i'm a fan these are these
were actually like i know that you went
like and said i'm gonna get something
disgusting
and i think you even said that when you
showed them to me you're like this is
going to be like really gross i'm like i
don't know they sound kind of good yeah
they're good and they are good real good
they are actually really good
i kind of suspected that might happen i
kind of suspected
and i think the same thing will happen
when we get pumpkin spice things because
i think most of the pumpkin spice things
will be delicious because i love that
kind of [ __ ]
um let's see wait a minute uh rebecca
said they don't sell any modelo flavored
beer here
and the one type they do sell is a small
glass beer bottle and it's [ __ ]
expensive yeah
that's a shame
too bad you'd have to order it
it's got a nice head on it
i mean you think that you'd be able to
get something like similar
i would imagine see if you can get a uh
it's called
a shellada
c-h-e-l-a-d-a shalabha
and there's a lot of recipes you can
make
you can make those
out of pilsners and
beers yeah that's fine you could
probably make one at home probably make
your own
for a lot cheaper yeah
rebecca said uh jeffy are you just
reminding me the cheesy bread from old
times sizzler
i love that stuff
mmm cheesy bread
yeah i mean
red lobster i like a lot of red lobsters
food but yeah those cheesy biscuits are
kind of like the main reason to go
mango said we do have a marmite beer
here in the uk that sounds
revolting
it's kind of like you know you know
vegemite okay
yeah it's um i've heard vegemite is not
very flavorful
i don't know that sounds pretty gross
rebecca said i always have ice and beer
and wine but i freeze green grapes and
uses ice because it's so damn hot most
that's actually a good idea yeah because
i really like frozen green grapes to be
honest with you
no the enchilada is sucking swinging i
like it
and rebecca said i've had mango beer
here before but no spice in it that i
remember
it's a good mixture it's good it's
everything
it's everything all happening at once
yes the salt on the rim makes it it
really does it kind of enhances
everything
manga said it is bloody awful and i love
marmite
which
that says something right there
uh hugo said budweiser has uh enchiladas
too but they're not good but they're not
good okay
yeah
that's what i mean i thought that was
kind of like a pretty popular
drink in certain circles
so i figured like some other
companies probably made them
that's that's not bad i'm just saying i
don't i don't really like mango flavored
things you like the uh pina yeah i like
the i think i like the pineapple the
best but the orange was really good too
between the pineapple and the orange i
think i liked the orange yeah
i mean they were all good though yeah
yeah they're all good just to do their
ranking order they're all good i think
the best one for me was that mango
the mango chili
rebecca said vegemite beer sounds
[ __ ] gross it does doesn't it that
sounds really disgusting
i mean i've never eaten vegemite or
marmite but i've smelled them
and just from the smell alone yeah i
don't think that would be a good idea i
think that'd be a good idea
he only rents shilata so
yeah do they even say that anymore that
you only rat beer
because it goes through you so quick but
um yeah so what was i gonna say oh i was
gonna say i kind of feel like nowadays
it's not just food but like
you know booze and stuff too they're
always like every day i see some like
weird ass
combo where like somebody's coming up
because there's i read like a blog
called the take out which is um you know
like a lot of food news and stuff and
every day it seems that somebody
somewhere is coming up with some bizarre
ass
combo like trying to get
[ __ ] people to
talk about it on tick tock or whatever
the [ __ ]
so what was the latest thing that i saw
uh
man it was something to do
with
i want to say it was fruity pebbles what
were they using but the which i don't
like fruity pebbles anyway
and
was it a donut i can't even remember
what it was it was something that used
fruity pebbles and i was just kind of
horrified
but i can't remember what it was i think
we were talking about this a little bit
because
when we saw that um
that new
sylvester stallone movie uh samaritan
where he was eating some cereal that
kind of looked like fruity pebbles then
he was putting apple juice instead of
milk in it
and i was like that sounds like some
[ __ ] though like some people would do
nowadays it's like look how gross this
is it's like i don't know just try to
get attention a lot of that stuff i
think is kind of probably disgusting
but
who knows it might be good you never
know you never know
rebecca said most australians are
[ __ ] and tell people to use vegemite
like nutella
i'm not falling for that like i said
i've never eaten it but i've smelled it
for sure and i'm just like that is
absolutely not nutella nutella is the
nectar of the gods
but
you guys i think we put this in our um i
think we put this in our cookbook but
man we made peanut butter cookies one
time
and i was like you know what we should
do with the peanut butter cookie batter
we should put it in little
cupcake tin like but you know so we have
like a little cookie shell at the bottom
and then put nutella in that [ __ ]
and we did that like well you gotta cook
it first obviously and then you put the
nutella in it and then you freeze it so
it hardens holy [ __ ] those were so good
oh my god
uh louis said jenny there's a movie on
hbo max called spartan from 2004
starring val kilmer at britain and
directed by david mamet real good movie
in my opinion okay we'll have to check
that out um because i do have hbmx
and
let's see
write that down so i try to like
write everything down so i can
transfer it over to my other
pookie did what
did you find her yeah
oh we're wondering where pookie's at
because very top apartment
she's
sleeping she's in her penthouse yeah
she's in the penthouse
she's looking at me like what do you
want she's either in the penthouse or
the bowl yeah the bowl because there's
three apartments we call them a little
apartment
they're like little things like that and
then like there's bowls
on either so she either likes to be in
the bowl or in the living room we'll
make another drink here yeah why not
because you can drink that mango one i'm
not like be a big fan of that
mango said i can eat marmite out of a
jar with a spoon
okay
[Laughter]
you do you i'm not doing that but
you know
man we made some sandwiches the other
night with
with cookie butter
it was like i don't even remember what
time it was it's like it was it was late
we were like watching a movie or
something like that
and i was like i'm gonna make some
cookie butter sandwiches man that [ __ ]
was delicious
ah
i missed the sizzler now is okay
is this the same scissor because we used
to have sizzlers in the u.s i'm pretty
sure that was a chain right it was like
kind of a low budget like steakhouse
because i remember going there as a kid
i don't think they have them anymore
but
yeah you go there and get like a shitty
overcooked steak and they had
a salad bar
and
i thought that it was like a
cafeteria setup but i could be
remembering that wrong do you remember
the sizzler
yeah
it was was it like a cafeteria thing
kind of yeah okay so i'm not gonna go
through and you had to get it that's
right so i'm not remembering that
because i remember going there because i
was a little little kid
little kid it was a steakhouse that was
set up like a
cafeteria you went through there and you
got what you wanted and you paid for all
right so i'm not crazy no i'm not crazy
no
and they were uh decent
that was back when you could get a steak
for a few bucks i remember that they
always overcooked their steaks though
well of course they sat there in those
damn that's what i'm saying um because
they're the heat in this in the in the
steam table because man if i'm gonna
have a steak i want that [ __ ] rare
well i think you could order
some of the steaks you could order yeah
like t-bones and roundhouse portals
right you can make them to order but
then they had other steaks that were
just there and the steam table stacked
up right you could get they were all
going well if you want overcooked balls
well done
they were cheaper
yeah they were cheaper
because i remember even as a child
because even as a child i was like man
give me that [ __ ] raw but almost raw but
it's just kind of like even when we
would go to like on the rare occasions
we would go to steakhouse and stuff
every time i ordered one i was like rare
and i'm serious they would always give
it to me like medium rare medium rare or
well to well done and i'm just like what
the [ __ ] are you even doing well i
remember that it's sizzlers you went in
and on the wall they had plaques that
had certain prices and everything you
could get like [ __ ] t-bone to order
three sides of this and two sides of
that and this for a certain amount of
money you had they had a bunch of them
up there
here you go i'm gonna get that and then
you [ __ ] go through it at the end you
tell them which one you wanted right
at the beginning maybe
you told them that you were one yeah see
i thought it was like that now so also
count said that was quincy's but i mean
yeah we had quincy's too but i think
they were similar i think they were
similar i mean i only went to sizzlers
like a few times yeah and i think
longhorn was set up kind of like that
too no longhorn is like a that's still
around that's more like a sit down
it's like texas roadhouse or whatever
the [ __ ] that thing is called we still
have some of that i'm pretty sure i'm
pretty sure that i'm pretty sure yeah i
haven't seen a single
at least 20 years yeah i think sizzler
had
competition though
and it was like a
like you said
like a uh like a cafeteria
but it was just now one steakhouse i
don't know if this was a chain or not
but when i was a little kid and i grew
up in daytona beach
and my grandma and my great-aunt like
her sister
used to take me to the volusia mall
which is still there
and when i was a kid they had a york's
steakhouse
now i don't remember if that was we
didn't go there that often because it
was a little bit more expensive we
usually went to wags which was more like
a well i don't know it was more like a
regular restaurant i guess with like
sandwiches and whatnot
so every now and then though we would go
to york steakhouse and i was always
excited because like i said i loved
steak but i liked it rare like i liked
rare steak and a baked potato
and they never got it rare enough for me
i was like i want it kind of like bloody
still and they thought i wasn't serious
because i was a kid i don't really know
how that worked but they always gave it
to me like overcooked
so
maybe so i don't know if that was a
chain though because there was one in
the mall
but
i never saw one anywhere else now
sizzler
that was usually like oh look at poke
yeah hi pokey you want to be on the show
you know you can tell she doesn't really
want to be i do not want to be on the
show she wants to play with toys i don't
want to be able to play toys though
i've got all these toys i got to play
with
uh altscount said golden corral is here
in north carolina i loved quincy's yeah
i think we had some golden corrals here
too so yeah quincy's i remember quincy's
i think i only ate there maybe once or
twice in my entire life i remember
quincy's for one thing big fat yeast
roll
remember that commercial big fat yeast
roll does anybody remember that but me
okay i'm crazy clearly um two
i thought that their big thing was pies
like you'd go in there like buy pies am
i thinking of something else i don't
know i'm pretty sure everyone heard this
place you talk about quincy's there was
one in daytona
it's a chain i wasn't here that's true
everybody says hey pookie yeah she
didn't want to play up here she's down
there with the toys she's got a whole
pile of toys she's sitting on top of him
i know he gets like over here she's got
like all her toys like in a little pile
all these little her little mouse toys
and she's got a hit a cat a little
dracula
she's got these little things she's
sitting on top of him shaking her head
and doing it
washing her paws and shaking her head
going no no
and then she's looking at the toys
you live a beautiful life pokey you
don't have to worry about bills or
anything
that's i keep telling her that all the
time she has no idea
i keep telling her that all the time she
i was saying you were the most spoiled
kitty that's ever lived
there was uh this channel i subscribed
to that had all those damn
[ __ ] uh cartel videos on it they
posted one today it was called
uh one [ __ ] nine puppies and [ __ ]
and as soon as i saw the [ __ ] female
dog there and the puppies like nope nope
not gonna watch it i had unsubscribing
that [ __ ]
and i went well what happens don't oh
and i was like please don't tell me yeah
that dude made a video about the video
saying
but man i was just like
that's still [ __ ] me up that somebody
could do that to a dog please don't tell
me yeah like i said it's not i mean i'm
not saying that it's good and if you
guys watch like my book review yeah uh
channel or my uh you know my other movie
review channel like sometimes because i
know that there's kind of a thing like
in horror it's like oh to be edgy it's
like yeah it's not really all that edgy
to like do horrible [ __ ] to people
anymore because no one cares but it's
like oh we're gonna do something really
[ __ ] up so like a dog or a cat i'm
just like nope
nope
that will that upsets me like way more
people care about what happens to humans
it's just that yeah i'm not saying i
don't care i'm just saying there's a big
difference between
animals that are totally helpless and
[ __ ] innocent of anything right and
uh people that are fighting
in the cartel videos there's an element
of [ __ ] well you called that [ __ ] on
yourself you know what i mean you
shouldn't have been involved with those
dudes you pulled that at photography
having a military background i
understand this [ __ ] you know you live
by the sword you die by the sword i mean
it's still [ __ ] up but
but still man [ __ ] just dogs i mean
there's absolutely no reason yeah trust
in human beings and honestly i can't
even watch
i don't know if i'm just getting like
sensitive in my old age like i said i
can still watch horror movies where bad
[ __ ] happens to humans i don't give a
crap about that but it's just kind of
like
the older i get the more and i guess
since we've got pookie i was like i
can't it's probably that i can't watch
anything even did the [ __ ] man i was
re-watching
the dario argenta movie deep red today
and there's a scene in there where like
somebody sticks a pin they're like
through a lizard and i can't even watch
that
yeah
you can do [ __ ] to humans i don't care
but like don't do [ __ ] [ __ ] to
animals but animals are innocent that's
what i mean they don't know no if you
get they don't understand what's going
on if you're gonna eat the animal that's
one thing i mean they eat each other
alive
but just for [ __ ] shits and giggles
no it's totally unnecessary
and [ __ ] once i found once i heard
what that dude did
i hadn't [ __ ] done worse to him
because i was imagining that there's
like no excuse for that there's no
excuse why would you do that i might
walk
if he ever got a hold of [ __ ] pookie
does some [ __ ] like that that's what i
mean i don't even want to think about it
i don't want to think about it i have
[ __ ] nightmares about bad stuff
happened to pookie and i know it's like
it's bad because it's like i don't have
any human children yeah but
pookie is like my furry child
so i have the same very protective
instincts
but he's a personality though that's
what i see her all the time and she does
things and i'm like i start laughing and
then she's like yeah
i mean you know they're not humans but
they're
she's like a person they're like people
yeah i mean i know that that's like
weird to say because like some people
that are fat but she's she knows she
exists she knows she's here she knows
what's happening you know what i mean
she's very interactive and it's like she
acts a lot like a kid a lot of times
like she'll do the same [ __ ] that like a
child would do
like she makes faces like a kid would
make she like reacts the same way to
things that a kid would yeah and it's
just so it's kind of like she she comes
across very much like a little tiny
furry person to me yeah and domestic
animals really have done they've done
nothing wrong
and they were raised to serve mankind
the dogs the cats everything you know i
can't somebody i can't believe somebody
betraying the trust
i mean i put horses down
i put dogs down
but there was always a reason and it was
it was
because
they were at the end of their life and i
didn't want to see these animals suffer
from cancer right sure that's like
something that's different right
you know or like uh
but you know that's different than
making an animal suffer yeah like why
the [ __ ] would you do that yeah stupid
um ultacon said pookie has been here
since day one yeah we've actually well i
don't know because we've had her when
did we get her 2017.
yeah we got her in 2017 when she was a
baby baby yeah pookie thinks she's a
human she doesn't know oh she absolutely
thinks she doesn't know she's a cat i
don't think she knows she's
she absolutely thinks she's a person
yeah she acts like a person she makes
faces like a person
whatever you're doing she's got to see
it get involved in it look at you like
why'd that happen
she wants to look at the tablet why are
those men talking what are they saying
you put the earbuds you do something
that makes her mad and she makes a face
like
her little like brows go like that like
she makes a little mad face at you
yeah so she definitely has an awareness
yeah they're
they're sentient
i don't think they [ __ ] questioned
much but that's not what they're made
for they're doing what they're supposed
to do
jeffy art said i don't trust people who
don't like animals yeah me either or at
least have some connection with them
it's a huge red flag for me yeah i mean
i kind of feel like that might be one of
the main things that kind of says you're
a sociopath yeah
i can [ __ ] people up
but they're bad
i mean i wouldn't have done it if they
weren't that's what i'm saying
it's like yeah if a person did if i got
my hands on like some [ __ ] serial
killer or some [ __ ] like some of the
[ __ ] we've talked about on this
show i would absolutely have no i
wouldn't feel bad at all i wouldn't lose
any sleep or anything like that about
like torturing and killing that person
but man it comes to like cats dog [ __ ]
like that i don't yeah no that that's a
totally different it's a totally
different thing
cesapea said sounds terrible but i've
mourned the loss of my pets harder than
i mourn people i mean i get that
honestly
when i was younger we had a
a bunch of kittens and one of them got
run over and this was like a long and it
still like upsets me like talking about
it but um one of them got run over and i
was like really really really upset
about it and i think i
cried more about that than when my
grandfather died
i mean
you know it's not that i didn't like my
grandfather it's just that you know he
was sick and it wasn't like a big
surprise or anything like that
i don't know it's just kind of like
you know
uh altogether said i have a friend who's
afraid of animals
what do you think
okay i'm gonna like when i was a little
kid
i wasn't afraid of
cats but i was afraid of dogs
because i mean to me when i was little
um you know i had family members and
friends and stuff like that i would go
to their house and they had dogs and to
me like dogs were i mean i'm very um
shy and very introverted and i don't
like uh
a lot of noise or like chaos or whatever
so
when i would go to people's houses and
they'd have dogs like it seemed i was
like oh my god here's this big huge
animal and it's jumping on me and it's
making all this noise and it's trying to
like interact and like lick my face and
it was like really upsetting so i didn't
so i didn't really like dogs for a long
time like i didn't hate them but i was
just kind of like yeah not really my
thing i always liked cats though
but
i don't know like as i got older that
kind of like
you know i toned that down a little bit
but
i don't like i get why you'd be afraid
of them because they do [ __ ] and you're
not really sure what their motivations
are
you know what's weird like our friend we
were just talking about her the other
day
our friend had a
daughter i mean she still has a daughter
but the daughter's uh you know grown now
but when she was a little kid
she came to our house and i think this
was before we got pookie right
and she was terrified of beijing our cat
and we thought that was so i think she
was five or six at the time yeah and i
was like okay i i get being afraid of
dogs because i was afraid of dogs when i
was little because dogs are big and loud
and they bark and they jump on you and
drool on you and [ __ ] like that like i
get that
and they can bite and [ __ ] i mean cats
can bite too but it's not really the
same thing
but i never heard of a little kid being
afraid of cats before a little kid was a
[ __ ] weirdo
i mean i mean she's probably better now
i don't know but
seth is in the audience hi bad says me
and says we're [ __ ] talking about the
other day
asked her how she was doing and we
started talking about what it's like to
sit around and just be beautiful like a
beautiful lion so i'm [ __ ] trading
pictures of a [ __ ] lie it's just be
this is that's what i'm doing and that's
what you're doing just sitting around
being beautiful ate that some [ __ ]
sitting around just sitting around being
beautiful [ __ ] yeah eating and being
beautiful
i wish i could get away with that i made
it up
i made that concept
you're sitting around being beautiful
sitting around being beautiful
like a lion
and then you share a picture of a
[ __ ] male lion and [ __ ] that's what
they do
well yeah they just i know they don't
have to do it like well the the female
lions go out and do all the hunting and
stuff yeah they're all they're all out
doing all the work
and the mail lines are just like bye
honey yeah i'm just i'm just gonna lay
here and like be beautiful
beautiful maine yeah well they fight
each other well i know that but it's
like how how often does that happen once
every blue moon that and they don't
really have to no to be honest they just
kick each other out of the [ __ ] tribe
yeah you're getting too many females you
got to go you're getting too old that's
really what that's all about i'm taking
over
yeah [ __ ] funny
and then meanwhile like the lady lions
are just like are you guys going to get
off the couch or what
we're watching over and over again the
female lioness don't care who the male
lion is they don't give a [ __ ] well
they're interchangeable to them probably
they're worried about [ __ ] raising
cubs yeah they're like whatever you just
lay around on the couch yeah being
pretty look yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna go
out and like actually get food for my
children yeah
yeah they catch [ __ ] you use this
[ __ ] yeah they catch [ __ ] he
shows up
what you catch okay stan is that oh can
i have some of that yeah let me eat some
of this
and then meanwhile like the female line
is like [ __ ] why don't you go and get
your own [ __ ] your arms are broken yeah
and then sundown's coming
all the females on the cubs are up in
there and in the whole pride they're all
[ __ ] they're all bunched up around
him he's standing around looking around
and pouring looking out at the set in
the sun like i'm defending these women
from those other men
meanwhile the other men the women are
like they're like
[ __ ]
they're doing that josh if lions could
do that yeah
the other men that the women that the
women think that are cuter than you
oh my god yeah but the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] lions are funny
but like i said i can see because we're
talking about being afraid of animals i
can see being afraid like especially as
a kid i can see being afraid of certain
animals like i said when i was a kid i
was afraid of dogs um and i would go to
uh you know zoos petting zoo stuff like
that i was afraid of the ostriches
because those [ __ ] are [ __ ] holy
[ __ ]
i got i didn't get bit by one but i had
one grabbed my hair when i was a little
kid that's yeah and you grab your hair
they're they're very aggressive
um they'll try to like kick you and
stuff so i was like afraid of that but
i don't know i kind of got over it as i
get older but it is weird like i said it
is weird that our friend's daughter when
she was little was afraid of cats i
never heard of that ever a little chick
was weird i never heard of that ever
i mean cats are so small yeah they can
[ __ ] you up i'm not saying that
sent to beijing sent time to the
hospital yeah for almost a week an
accident though for it was accidental
she didn't mean to but um you know so it
can't happen but
i don't know they're so little yeah
louis says the scissors were fine dining
back in the day yeah they were yeah they
were good i liked them well like i said
a little kid i mean when i was a kid
yeah
i mean we never we hardly ever ate out
because we you know we didn't have a lot
of money so
i mean just going to mcdonald's was like
a big deal because we hardly ever went
so if we were going to like [ __ ]
arthur treacher's or
you know some place where you could
actually like sit down like back when
pizza hut was sitting down that was like
a big deal that only happened like a few
times a year maybe
john mentioned some [ __ ] that's true
said fauci did some [ __ ] bad [ __ ] the
dogs yeah
factory was involved in this company it
bought a bunch of surplus beagles that
were on the market there was like a
bunch of beagles they were trying to get
rid of they bought every one of them
beagles
[ __ ] cut their [ __ ] larynx out of
them so they couldn't bark
tied them down to a [ __ ] bed put a
[ __ ] thing around their head and had
sand flies
[ __ ] bite him in the head
for some kind of medicine that they were
working on
which i can understand you know if
you're doing animal experimentations on
some kind of a cure
to save human beings it's real important
but the more i found out about that
those medical companies and these guys
that start this [ __ ] up is more like a
scam
they did that kind of for nothing they
didn't have to
uh but
that's how they kind of like
raise money to have these [ __ ]
treatments made even though they don't
sell well on the market
i'm not a big believer in animal
experimentation i don't only in is that
should only be a last resort i mean i
kind of feel like that's last resort
last resort and and what's funny is that
they're doing those animal
experimentations on these animals
for [ __ ] mundane [ __ ] cures that
they know would work
you know it's just no i shouldn't be
doing that [ __ ]
well you know how for a long time they
would even do crap like
um you know there were companies that
made like cosmetics and stuff yeah they
were experimenting like
rabbits and [ __ ] like that so now like
you have a bunch of where everything's
like cruelty free and everything like
that which like i said look
we've got to this stage we know how [ __ ]
works you don't have to experiment on it
anymore yeah and it's just cosmetics
it's not like life-shattering it's not
gonna like save anybody's life or
anything like that they would take like
a bunch of rabbits and tie them up
and drop [ __ ] um
watered down shampoo into their eyes
over and over and over again until the
eye damn rotted out
when we know don't get shampoo in your
goddamn eyes
that's all you know in the [ __ ] and
the thing is like is that necessary
because nobody is like sitting there
going dropping that [ __ ] in their eye
over and over and over oh [ __ ] i'm going
to see you no no just it was just knock
it off it was the law yeah it does the
thinking don't do that don't put [ __ ]
shampoo in your [ __ ] eyes
over and over and over again they just
did stupid [ __ ]
uh and there was money was involved you
know [ __ ] companies would come out
well we'll make sure that we'll know
everything about your [ __ ] and that
was like johnson and johnson shampoo
that they did that i think it was back
in the 50s
now it's safe on your eyes we know how
many how many drops it takes to burn
your eye out and you'll never drop that
many drops in your eye and they they
hired that company to do all that [ __ ]
just to say that it was safe
because we found the [ __ ] extreme
edge
stupid
don't get shampoo in your [ __ ] eyes
i mean really all they'd have to do like
to cover their own ass is just put that
on the back of the bottle
don't pour this in your eyes dumb ass
but then it was safe for children we
killed a thousand we blinded a thousand
rabbits and then euthanized them just to
find out that you got to put so much
[ __ ] [ __ ] in those rabbit's eyes to
destroy them like i said that they'll
never have it's just stupid
stupid because they hired a [ __ ]
company to research that as johnson and
joshua did so they could say that it's
safe it's safe
and uh
just dumb like i said after a certain
point like i said i can get if it's like
a life or death drug
or something like that but if it's just
like i said something like shampoo or
cosmetics it's really not
that big a deal and most people look if
you're stupid enough to just sit there
and pour shampoo in your eyeballs you
don't deserve it then yeah right yeah
i'm not really sure what to tell you if
no one's there like to stop you from
doing that
that [ __ ] yeah
rebecca said why the hell is the medical
and beauty industry experimenting at
innocent animals when they're [ __ ]
animals oops on
sitting in prison and on death row yeah
i mean i'm
to be honest i'm a big advocate look if
you know that that [ __ ] did some
[ __ ] like some serial killers they could
contribute to the the well-being of
society as a whole experiment on them
the chinese would do that leave the
goddamn you know i know there are
ethical things and like i said you have
to one you have to be absolutely sure
that that [ __ ] is guilty okay
look okay what was the show we did the
other day about those [ __ ] toolbox
kills yeah they were guilty okay
so they admitted to that [ __ ] and went
to prison i kind of feel like after that
point
would i would much rather have
[ __ ] like those experimenters
leave the bunnies alone leave the bunny
they get a little teenage girl and hit
her in the elbow [ __ ] 25 times with a
[ __ ] iron mallet until her [ __ ]
elbow was [ __ ] [ __ ] i would not lose
any sleep in fact i would personally
yeah go and pour shampoo in their eyes
over and over again what's funny is that
you look at those dudes and they're just
[ __ ] weak little men you know i mean
and just well of course they are if they
weren't they wouldn't have to do that
crap
if they weren't they wouldn't have to do
that i don't want to say nothing
i don't want to say [ __ ] what i would
[ __ ] when i hear about that [ __ ] how
mad i get and what i wanted well you got
cops that i grew up with in the comments
section i do too but [ __ ] it's the
[ __ ] we went through in the [ __ ]
service the way we would torture
ourselves to [ __ ] uh find out who was
the [ __ ] had the most [ __ ] ability
to to
the most ability to just [ __ ] endure
you know what i mean and these dudes had
easy [ __ ] lives they were weak men
and they'd go out and do that to [ __ ]
innocent people it makes me just want to
[ __ ] crush them you know what i mean
it makes me want to go after their
parents for raising them that way yeah
well see i don't want to go that far no
i get like north korean well no i don't
want to go that far because i'm trying
to go three generations of punishment no
no no i'm like north korea
because like i said i could
i could
imagine
that because i know that serial killers
not necessarily born it has to be kind
of like a perfect storm and i'm not
saying that some of them didn't have
[ __ ] up childhoods they did but i
think that some of them there had to be
some genetic component and i don't think
necessarily all the time that the
parents are to blame because i kind of
feel like that's the first thing that a
lot of people want to jump to it's like
oh their mom and their dad like [ __ ]
him up or whatever and in some cases i
think that's true but i don't think you
could necessarily because i kind of
think to myself what the [ __ ] would
happen if i had a kid and that kid for
whatever reason even though i tried to
raise them to the best of my abilities
what if they turned out to be like some
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] that like went out
and killed a bunch of people and then
everybody would blame me and it's like i
didn't do anything like you know what i
mean so i kind of like am coming at it
from that now i am saying that like some
of them do have like really [ __ ] up
parents i'm not saying that but i
wouldn't
jump to
blaming them i said that [ __ ] is
an adult
they're an adult and they chose to do
what they did i think you should just
blame that person yeah don't blame their
parents
how long have you been talking like that
two hours and 15. okay so we're now in
in the show heavy well yeah it's eight
o'clock we're heavy in the show we're
heavy in the show
okay i'm just saying
if you guys have any questions you guys
want to talk about anything man we're
we're primed up
we're already talking about today
altogether said thanks for the feedback
my friend wants to love pets honestly um
and the thing about it is that you
really have to think like animal like
domestic animals are
just like people like some of them are
you know better with some personalities
than others i've had cats my whole life
and
i've had some cats that were very aloof
and didn't really want to hang with you
and then i've had
cats like pookie
that were just kind of like little tiny
people
in little fuzzy coats
where she's just like eye contact facial
expressions and everything and she just
wants to get involved like hey what you
doing jumping up on my desk in the
middle of like hey can we like can i
type and i'm going to be watching like
what you're doing she just like wants to
get involved in everything and she's the
first cat that i've ever had that was
like that yeah and i think like grogu
from [ __ ] mandalorian it's very
similar to like little grogo
she does kind of remind me of making
little she reminds me of baby yoda yeah
[Laughter]
she um
when when tom goes in his man cave
and you know to watch his tablet or
whatever
at night she will sit right outside the
door and guard it and make sure the
[ __ ] beige doesn't come up she
doesn't want beijing coming up is coming
up on me yeah
[ __ ] funny she thinks beijing is like
some kind of well she's trying to
dominate villain
she laughs at beijing she doesn't want
beijing coming up because i belong to
her she doesn't want beijing coming up
beau garden
she's a [ __ ] beijing kind of
[ __ ] block yeah i think that's what it
is
she's like i'm protecting daddy yeah
he belongs to this is my person yeah
this is my person yeah don't go over
here that's what she's doing well she
did that the other day too because like
i said she saw me talking to beijing was
mad about it yeah she gets upset she's
like
oh
oh
oh no they get i mean they tolerate each
other the two of them
but since we moved to the house that has
two floors
beijing like took over the bottom floor
pookie stays up here usually
but she'll usually sometimes she'll go
down there and like [ __ ] around with
beijing so every now and then like
beijing will come try to come upstairs
and pookie will like
so she
puki is taken to kind of like sitting
either on
like right at the top of the stairs or
she sits like right in front of tom's
man cave which is like
just a couple feet from the top of the
stairs and she just like sits there and
watches like all day like hours long the
other day beijing came up into my office
which she hardly ever does
and started eating off of beijing's
plate
because i put a little dish there that
has like some wet food in it
and she came up and started eating it
and pookie was oh she was so put out and
she i mean she like peeked around the
corner my dad she's like what the [ __ ]
is that [ __ ] doing in here and she like
jumped down there and there was like a
whole big thing they had like a whole
big situation about it it's just like so
funny i don't like i said they don't
they don't fight as much as they used to
because when we first got pokey and she
was like a tiny tiny kitten and beijing
at that point was you know obviously a
grown woman and she was like what is
this baby doing in my house i don't like
it
um so there was a lot of uh turmoil
there because beijing was like i'm the
baby why am i being replaced
so we tried to like convince her that
she wasn't being replaced but she wasn't
buying it so she got like really really
cranky about it
and she got like super snotty she's
always been kind of snotty you know what
i mean we always called her
even from before we even got pokey uh
tom was always like yeah she's like the
paris hilton of cats because
she's very very aloof and she's very
beautiful like with her she's a rag doll
and she like has her beautiful long hair
and she's just obviously struts around
like she's a princess and she's just
like i'm just
she's very much like that so when pookie
came
who was a kitten and pookie even now
that she's five is
kind of like a tomboy she's very much
like
blah blah blah she's like kind of like a
goofball and she just kind of like
he's just like i don't care i do what i
want
she's kind of like that and beijing was
just not having it she was not having it
she was like i don't i don't like this i
don't like the situation at all but as
it is they kind of tolerate each other
but
um when if beijing ever tries to come
upstairs pookie gets like really upset
and like tries to like chase her
down
you know and she always guards
in the middle of the night like i'll get
up in the middle and i took her to the
bathroom and she'll be sitting at the
top of the stairs
watching
like making sure beijing doesn't come up
in the middle of the night it's
hilarious
okay so the modelo beers flavored beers
were good
real good
they're great yeah i liked those a lot
actually
they're like summertime tropical drinks
you put ice in them salt the ring
i'm gonna buy those again
i'd buy that again
ilio says where is that raccoon
i don't know what a raccoon well let's
find out
[Music]
[Laughter]
i haven't used that a long time i keep
forgetting that i have that yeah
uh yeah john gore said cats don't like
interlopers
yeah i mean the dynamic between the two
of them is funny
they'll hang out together like sometimes
i'll go downstairs and
pookie will be laying on the back of the
couch on this end and beijing will be
laying on the back of the couch on this
end and they're like tolerating it
but yeah
jeffrey hart uh says that he agrees with
my
gat uh leaded gasoline theory
remember with all these [ __ ] crazy
ass serial killers and [ __ ]
i came up with that because i remembered
leaded gasoline
and i was driving cars that ran it
and i remember catching whiffs of that
[ __ ] when i was filling up my car
and you'd feel kind of high afterwards
and
uh later on i found out how [ __ ]
lead poisoning can lower iqs and make a
person real damn violent
and how the lead pipes inside of ancient
rome
ancient ancient city of rome the capital
the lead pipes probably were they went
all to the richest neighborhoods of the
[ __ ] of rome
and in the roman [ __ ]
aristocracy were [ __ ] crazy
they were violent and [ __ ]
uh would come up with some crazy [ __ ]
so i started thinking you know
internal combustion inside those car
engines that doesn't destroy lead it
just blows it out the damn [ __ ]
tail pipe
banana tail pipe so anyway
so that means that there was little lead
particles flowing out everywhere
and i remember seeing they had leaded
gasoline and unleaded gasoline at the
pump
which mystified me
back in the 80s
i was like why is
why are there two different kinds of
gasoline what's the difference and then
they slowly started phasing out leaded
then there was only unleaded
and i said what was all that leaded [ __ ]
about and why'd they get rid of it
and i'd ask some older people
they were like 20 years older than me oh
yeah that leaded stuff yeah that that
you don't need that that was old cars
and which mystified me even more
if that leaded gas if that leaded
gasoline
was necessary it wouldn't if it was
necessary they never would have never
gotten rid of it
they would have never replaced that
so it was unnecessary whatever it was
and i'm convinced
the fuel companies sidesteps were
sidestepping some kind of lawsuit they
had to have known something was wrong
with that leaded gasoline
if you lived in a place like california
down in the san fernando valley which is
the big ass basin full of [ __ ] houses
i bet you there were a [ __ ] ton of damn
[ __ ] lead particles built up in there
and that's where a lot of these [ __ ]
psychos were
you know they were just weren't anywhere
now i'm not saying
lead was responsible for all of them but
i bet you that was a contributing factor
i think that was a big contributing
factor but it was not only that [ __ ] but
a lot of violence
lead particles
make you [ __ ] crazy
yeah well it it really does kind of like
[ __ ] with your lowers inhibitions and
increases violence yeah
and they had to have known
yeah i kind of feel like it's just kind
of i don't know like companies like that
they're like well we know this shit's
bad but if people don't find out about
it then we don't have to spend the money
to fix it
because they don't want to
so they're like let's try to keep it on
the dot on the download for as long as
possible my understanding leaded
gasoline came pretty early i think in
the 40s or something 30s and 40s
it was somebody's great idea to put
to the spin to suspend tiny lead
particles in gasoline
to make [ __ ] car engines run smoother
so the valves didn't [ __ ] slap when
they weren't closing kind of like an
additional lubricant
but it probably didn't work
probably wouldn't make a big humanity i
mean maybe it did but it's like even
then is it really worth it
now well and then they probably didn't
have any idea that lead was poisonous
but
it wouldn't have mattered it wouldn't
what i'm saying is is that that lead
in those old engines wouldn't have
mattered they didn't make very much
horse
the sealed in those valves didn't have
to be perfect anyway
so i don't think they weren't gaining
anything it probably made a car run a
little quieter but so what
you know
they didn't have noise emission
standards
i think it was just a cheap way of
selling
some kind of probably toxic waste to the
fuel companies some kind of contract i
got all this lead
buy this lead it'll [ __ ] be great
you're in your [ __ ] fuel it's like
that something like that probably like
oh yeah it sounds pretty good probably
is good like i said if there's a lot of
money to be made nobody really thinks
that much she thinks that harder
because leaded fuel didn't didn't seem
to give an advantage
to a car
not a measurable advantage
john gore said i knew some kids in high
school who huffed gas i did some stupid
things but we used to [ __ ] put gas in
our mouth and spit it out and try to
[ __ ] make a damn
and we i don't know how we didn't burn
our way you were like breathing fire you
were [ __ ] kids yeah did you light
your farts too tried all kinds of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i think what saved us with the [ __ ]
blowing fire is that we couldn't get
enough gas in our mouths because that
[ __ ] would [ __ ] just burn your mouth
up
back in the 70s you know
so it's probably even like less than a
teaspoon we were able to get in our
mouths because we never could blow fire
with it
because of course you tried yeah of
course
tried everything
never huffed gas i mean you'd have to be
like pretty desperate i feel like
you couldn't get you you couldn't get
your hands on like some better [ __ ] to
[ __ ] your ass up than
huffing gasoline
i mean little kids you tried anything
everything in brazil well
you did
i didn't do that were trying to get
benzene cleaning fluid and they were
[ __ ] putting that as sock and huffing
it getting real hard getting real high
on it then you get a shitty headache
then you wouldn't do it again see it's
like weird to me because
when i was a kid i don't know like i
always was just kind of like why the
[ __ ] would you want to do that just kid
be the kid
well i was a kid too yeah i don't it
just didn't occur to me i was just like
why the [ __ ] would you want to do that
that just really doesn't sound like
anything did you see what happened it
didn't sound like any fun to me kids
were stupid
maybe i wasn't a stupid kid maybe it was
actually
crazy you know you were you were not a
boy
well that's you but yeah but i had you
crazy well i had brothers they weren't
that i mean they did stupid [ __ ] too but
not that stupid
not that stupid well we didn't have like
a way of measuring
the amount of stupid
you know
there was no there was no stupid there
there there was no
[Laughter]
there was no scale first there's no
stupid scale no
it was all so you actually didn't know
if you were still on the scale or if
like you were off of it yeah so people
wouldn't be like bro you were like way
off the stupid scale right now like
let's talk about what you're doing
huffing benzene would be the same as
trying to make a damn
[ __ ] um uh
torch
torch out of gasoline and [ __ ] tar
with [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
rag and
be about the same as like trying to
you know
launch a rocket into the air using
[ __ ] you know
black powder that you stole from your
dad's reloading [ __ ] or for his black
his muzzleloader
okay now i think me and my brother did
that yeah there's all kinds of [ __ ] but
yeah well and we would get fireworks and
like [ __ ]
launch his gi joe's into space launching
yeah we did that but it's just kind of
like i never really i know i never like
um understood the appeal of
getting like gasoline or other like
chemicals and like huffing them i didn't
really i was just kind of like that
seems like it would just be a bit knock
you out it was a bad it seemed like it
was we only did it like once
you didn't do it like it could be at
best you didn't do it we never really
did it twice or three times it did like
once
just to see
and then like uh we had this
i had this toy it was a rocket it was a
clear plastic rocket that you could fill
with the water
and you could attach it to a base and
you could pump it and pump it and pump
it oh i know what you're doing
eventually that rock would go whoosh
yeah
yeah
we had one of those yeah it looked like
the [ __ ] saturn v rocket yeah we had
one of those yeah i had one of those
well we would shoot those at each other
because a lot of yeah it's had those we
did that all kinds of stuff yeah we did
that we would make dirt clouds you make
dirt clouds yeah just make a [ __ ] get
make mud pies and let them dry out and
it was like ammo yeah and then you start
shooting throwing them at each other
yeah yeah yeah we did that they have a
whole wars with them yeah dress up with
a motorcycle helmet and [ __ ] put on a
deck
just jack it like a [ __ ] oh i'm
invincible now because you got your dad
you got your dad's rain jacket on for
some crazy reason you know you can't
penetrate you need throwing [ __ ] stuff
then you and then you try to [ __ ] do
something high speed like my dirt clouds
have nails in them you know that kind of
stuff you know
yeah didn't make any difference but you
thought it did
and then you'd make rubber band guns and
[ __ ] shoot them dried [ __ ] kernel
corn at each other and yeah i remember
that all kinds of stuff yeah for a long
time my younger brother had um he had a
blow gun it had like the little needle
darts
he had those so we used to shoot those
at each other
yeah and throw darts at each other we
used to do that too
so what else is everybody doing what are
they saying in there uh let's see john
gore said i saw some documentary about
little kids in serbia or somewhere uh
some rough place and they were all
huffing paint solvents yeah they had
that mess all over their face i mean
yeah here's the thing i'm like i'm not
gonna judge because
look if okay
if you grow up in some like [ __ ]
where yeah you know that's the only
thing to do okay i can see it then but
honestly like me just out being as a kid
it's like it never really occurred to me
to like do anything like you can't do
that for long you're gonna get a bad
headache and you get sick of it that you
won't do it yeah it's just like to me i
was just like that doesn't really sound
like any fun burn up some of your brain
cells and then
kind of
[ __ ] that i didn't do that anymore i was
more into i don't know like when i was a
little kid i was like i think i'll just
like you know read some edgar allan poe
or something it's like i don't really
like huff some weird [ __ ] chemicals
mango says lead-free petrol equals less
serial killers not a bad thing but why
do so many people have peanut allergies
nowadays i don't recall anyone having
them yeah there's some kind of vaccine
that they did
well i don't know if it's that but it's
just kind of like uh oh thank you thank
you guama khan thank you how much money
did he send
9.99 oh damn this is being rich tgif
everybody hey you just got here just got
here personally i'm a fan of modelo and
a can so i hope to see all give it
glowing reviews when i rewatched this
that was good it's good yeah we're going
to tell you like spoiler alert all of
them were very good you were good i
wasn't a huge fan of the mango but i
don't like mango flavored things anyway
the pineapple one was my favorite but
the orange one was good too
yep
the orange was good you um put it you
drink it with ice with the salted brim
out of the can it was good yeah heated
the whole salt around the room and
everything yeah i like to
i like them all
i put them in this order number one
mango number two orange number three
pineapple but they were all good the
difference was just between eight and
ten i mean i liked it opposite i liked
pineapple was my favorite orange was my
second favorite mango was but like i
said i don't like mango flavored things
generally but that was actually really
good still for me for something yeah
mango had a chili it was mango chili it
had a little bit of heat but not much
the one that had the best heat on the
back of it was the pine was the orange
orange had the most heat i think i liked
the pineapple because it was kind of
like the mildest
yeah maybe
i don't know kind of tastes like cayenne
pepper at the end of it yeah they have a
good they're uh
kind of uh
light fruity and sweet
kind of like a uh you what what
enchilada what's this [ __ ] called it's
nicoletta michelada michelle is like an
enchilada michelada it's an enchilada
that's a totally different thing see
what you what you do is it's like you
know growing up in brazil
people would try to make mixed drinks
out of things that came out of cans
beer or wine
and you put ice in it and you mix some
other stuff and now you have a mixed
drink but it's not in hard liquor it's
in beer or wine and that's what that is
michelada it's
a mixed drink based in beer
so it's got ice in it it's got a [ __ ]
salted rim it's got a
spice profile it's got a a fruit profile
and beer profile and it's
all together in the same drink
and it's kind of light and summer
hot weather
summer drink it's not real strong you
drink a bunch of them
and
yeah it was good modela was
i don't know what their regular beer is
like that's not what i was here for
i wanted to taste those stems yeah we
wanted some weird [ __ ] yeah i wanted
something weird micheladas were good i'd
buy i'd buy them again actually all of
those i would not
i would absolutely buy all of those
again not probably maybe not the mango
because i'm not a mega she like the
orange but the other two were absolutely
delicious now there was a fourth one but
they were sold out i don't know what the
fourth one was that might have been
lemon
oh
now i'm intrigued it makes sense it was
probably something that was like lemon i
like lemon yeah
i like lemon
because that's the only thing i can see
that the only place where that would go
would be like lemon
like a mojito like a beer mojito
probably something like that
all right well
for next for the next friday show i'll
go with you so although somebody said
that we should do like pumpkin stuff
on the next one yeah i'll go look but
like i said
i like pumpkin stuff rebecca said liquid
paper smelled like white out yeah
smelled disgusting and kids at school
used to sniff that and i was wondering
what the [ __ ] is wrong i used to love
the way that smelled
yeah there's it's kind of like do you
remember like i know this is probably
like um yeah when you grow up in the 70s
and you had um before you had uh
printers
yeah and when they did a and you're
writing an egg
well no when they did um when they made
copies of
you know worksheets and stuff it was a
mimeograph yeah that you had in the
office
and the ink on that i don't even know if
it was ink i just or whatever it was and
it had a very distinctive smell
so that when they would pass out
the worksheets everybody would pick it
up and go
because it had like a really weird smell
to it
i kind of feel like
the liquid paper kind of smelled like
that but and markers too like if you got
like the marker that had like the really
strong like smell to it like i'd kind of
pick it up a second ago like that but
it's like i'm not gonna sit there and
huff it like enough for me to get high
off it because jesus christ why the [ __ ]
would i do that
it's just i don't know it never occurred
to me like i said i kind of feel like i
didn't even start drinking
which i think i brought up before i
didn't start drinking until i was in my
late 30s
when i was a teenager stuff like that
like i had a couple like i had some zima
because i was like
you know i had like a beer here and
there but
i didn't really grow up in a household
where alcohol was a thing no one really
cared about it um a lot of people i hung
out with some of them drank some of them
didn't nobody really talked about it and
it never really like occurred to me
because i know that there's like a big
culture
uh or there was back then it's like and
but i kind of feel like that was more
i don't know like where i grew up that
was more like jock cheerleader type
thing and they were just kind of like oh
we're going to this part oh we got so
[ __ ] up but i'm just kind of like okay
whatever lame so
i don't know like it never occurred to
me like i said some of my friends drank
and some of them didn't and nobody
really talked about it like nobody was
really like showing off oh my god we got
so [ __ ] up last night even though i'm
like only 16. so it never like really
occurred to me to
do that when i was younger because i'm
like that doesn't really sound like a
good time to me
so
like i said i don't really start
drinking until much much later much
later and it is fun but i'm glad that i
didn't start earlier because
you know i don't know what would happen
but
i don't know it just wasn't really
something that i
was that interested me like when i was
younger for whatever reason and same
thing with like i knew some people that
you know smoked weed i knew some people
that like did
acid i knew some people like that but
like nobody was really like people just
did it or not and like nobody really
talked about it or
were like oh my god i did this and that
and the other like no one was like
bragging about it or anything so it's
just like if you did it fine if you
didn't do it fine like nobody really
cared like one way or the other
so
i don't know so i feel like i didn't do
as crazy as [ __ ] as some people did like
in their teenage years how long does she
have been going
two hours and two hours and 38 39
minutes okay we're coming up on the end
making something to eat a bit in a
little bit in a bit yeah yeah rebecca
said i never understood the appeal yeah
i didn't really either it's just it just
seems like to me
i don't know like i kind of feel like if
you're gonna get [ __ ] up
um
go all the way like do the good [ __ ]
like why would you want to get [ __ ] up
it's like let's sniff white out it's
like come on
and surely use all the half i know but
they're kids but the thing about it is
that like if they really wanted to they
could probably like the kids i grew up
with like had money like their parents
had money so if they really wanted to
like get some like good [ __ ] they
probably could have
you know
mango said same here i never got it yeah
it's
i don't know
it just wasn't ever something like i
said i like drinking but i didn't really
start drinking until i was much much
older i never really got the appeal of
drinking when i was younger it just
wasn't something i did i knew people
that did it
but
it just wasn't really something that
sounded like all that good of a time to
me
you know
okay do you want um do you want uh
tacos do you or do you want uh meatloaf
well we had meatloaf earlier
i mean meatloaf is good too but i
thought i thought you said that you
wanted to make time yeah i think we
should
i mean it's up to you i'll eat it the
thing i don't know
let me get started on tacos i'm not
picky okay
both things are good all right both
things are good
so you sound like you wanna yeah we
gotta shut it down you wanna wrap it up
yeah you are right oh [ __ ] we're coming
up on three hours
well two hours and forty minutes that's
almost three coming up on three
unless you want to [ __ ] continue
continue to do the show look at pokey i
just started like sneak up behind you if
you want to continue to do the show you
can do it but if not i got to get down
and start getting something to eat oh
all right all right all right so i guess
we'll wrap it up okay
so we will be back we're going to take
tomorrow off
but we'll be back sunday we'll be either
talking about godfather 2
or
sicario okay whichever one we decide to
watch tomorrow all right uh that'll be
the one that we do
so hopefully you guys will come and hang
out with us again hopefully you guys
will have a good day tomorrow have a
good weekend up until then
so we will see you guys again on sunday
evening thanks for dropping by thanks
for all your super chats
and we will see you guys again on
sunday evening
bye